the next three hours is your chance to
participate in a discussion with one of
today's leading radical journalists
Jonah says in depth welcomes Alexander
Coburn columnist for the Nation magazine
and co-editor of the political
newsletter
counterpunch mr. Coburn's books includes
corruptions of empire the Golden Age is
in US and white out the CIA drugs in the
press his latest co-authored with
Jeffrey Sinclair is end times the death
of the Fourth Estate
[Music]
Alexander Coburn what does it mean to
you to be a radical it means basically
initially challenging pretty much
everything that's put before you I in
either audio or visual form or in
literature or in journalism
ellaby State has a social and political
vision behind it
I mean radicals like one of these words
like liberal it's very hard to even get
a fix on it anymore when I 20 years ago
liberal meant something very different
from what it does now I think radical
radical really means that you don't
necessarily regard in fact you
absolutely don't regard the Democratic
Party as about as far left as you can go
on the American political spectrum and
seriously to the left as far as I mean
there can be radical right-wingers you
know mad dog people and of left and
right but radical essentially means
really unsparing criticism of the system
and beyond it a constructive vision of
how things could be better when did you
first know that you were a radical uh
well when I my mother my father was a
radical my mother of course because he
was a journalist and he hoped he it was
tough we grew up in Ireland in the 50s
and my mother hoped that I'd be the
executive of an oil company and make
lots of money and by the time I was 16
when I was going on peace marches and
stuff like that I decided that I wanted
to be a journalist and I guess that's
when I really realized I wasn't going to
be an oil company executive I was going
to be a radical cause I was a radical
who is your father my father was claude
Coburn
very well-known journalist and writer
might be known in this country by many
younger people now if they have a go
watch movies under the name James he'll
Vicki wrote the novel beat the devil
which was made into a famous movie
filmed by John Huston but he was very
very well-known as he was fought in
Spain he was a communist in the 30s he
then became a sort of well-known again -
used the word radical he worked with
private eye which is a well-known
english satirical muckraking paper he
did volumes of autobiography in fact
counterpunch books are going to put
republish his memoirs under the title i
clawed in the fall and he was a huge
influence on me the movie from beat the
devil people might as you said might
have seen had what gina lollobrigida you
know larger bridge Lola Brigitte oh they
had Janet Lee they had Robert Morley
Humphrey Bogart yeah okay both uh it's
kind of a confusing movie it's a cult
movie people absolutely love it that the
script is attributed in the on the
credit to Truman Capote who I think
wrote the final scene but most of the
great lines in the movie which fans of
the movie can recite ad nauseam were
done by my dad who read it under the
name James Helbig because in the 50s in
the Cold War there Huston who is a
friend of my dad's didn't want this what
Claude Coburn would be kind of a bit
edgy because he was a communist
well McCarthyism was going on and they
didn't want to get you know on timely
questions raised but this was you know
the era of I guess house about an
American Activities Committee and so on
your father left the Communist Party
uh-huh when in the 40s why he thought he
didn't have some big he felt that it
just wasn't being effective it was just
it was going nowhere
I mean his the heroic period was the 30s
he fought in Spain in the Spanish Civil
War for the Republic he thought by the
late 40s they just weren't going
anywhere and he relocated I'm my
mother's Irish
we grew up in Ireland and he just
started a new life in Ireland
and in Ireland he was at the you know it
was
tough because Alan was a very poor
country and he was a lefty and the Cold
War was really getting going so we he
wrote the big kill if you could get it
was to get a story published in the
started Evening Post that was $5,000 in
1950s dollars and you could live through
a year on that so have you have you
spent any time thinking about what it is
about you that came from each of them
yeah they're a good deal I mean I think
I my fathers have taught me a lot about
writing and the disciplines of writing
you got up at 5:00 and whacked away on
his typewriter my mother was our country
person we grew up in the country
she she raised horses I got all my
liking of the country and horses and
just that kind of a life my father
didn't like horses thought they were
detestable and dangerous creatures so we
read divided on that so I think I got a
lot from both of them this is a picture
of you you must have been what three
four I don't know if we can show there
we go
there it is look at it there's the
sinister lefty in the background my
mother and the little that's the houses
Myrtle Grove which now belongs to my
cousin which is where Sir Walter Raleigh
smoked the first tobacco in Arlen he
used to live in that house and you lived
in Ireland because my that's when my
mother came from my mother hated England
and London she thought it was completely
detestable and so the minute she and my
father are met in the late 30s and we
spent the war kind of I was here back
and evacuee I was born in 41 and our
house was blown up by a v2 German v2 and
in what 42 or 43 and by 46 and 47 my
father was out of what he'd been doing
and then we went to Alan - my mother's
great belief where can people read you
today they can read me they can read me
every week on our counterpunch website
WWE and upon cor G we're out which
Jeffrey Sinclair a co-editor and I do
and the search site that goes up every
day five new articles and
most pretty much every weekend I have a
piece then I do a column and have done a
column since 1984 in the Nation magazine
beat the devil name for the movie which
I do all the time and then that's pretty
much these days if I do a syndicated
column which goes out to a bunch of
papers and counterpunch is also in a
printed form oh yeah I'm sorry
counterpunch we are twice a month we do
a newsletter counterpunch and 22 issues
a year and I quite often have articles
in that your newest book which just
recently came out a series of essays
along with Jeffrey Sinclair called
end times the death of the Fourth Estate
what is end times what is it well n
times is a play actually Jeffrey thought
about is a good title it it's well n
times of course in in apocalyptic
eschatology you know the end time is
like the end of everything but if you
look at it from the Christian
fundamentalist point of view so there
was a servers are slightly at the
Calypso tin that N times also the play
is because New York Times and it's
really about I think we've got to the
end of the the kind of the big print era
of the of the mainstream press there's a
quote on the back of it actually from
punch Salzberg of the chairman of the
New York Times saying he does that
they'll be printing the New York Times
at all in five years he said that in the
end of January this year and so well
what at the book really is is saying we
are nearing the end of the year that
five years ago what you said the
internet is really going to wipe out a
lot of the Fourth Estate as it now
exists people to sin I don't know about
that now you have a lot of big chains
are in really serious trouble Knight
Ridder got broken up which you know 20
years ago Knight Ridder was the you know
philadelphia inquirer the San Jose
Mercury News the Detroit Free Press
these were big big papers now that's on
the block you got the LA Times is up you
know what I just you know will Eli Broad
and his friend buy it from the Trib
that's an I mean I wrote for the LA
Times on their op-ed for ten years you
went in and it was a huge powerful rich
the dominant journalistic
in California we're still a big outfit
but you know it you know it's the usual
story with the print press a lot of
people have been taking you know early
retirement
you know the ads are all going away
because of Craig's lead you know the
story that's one bit of it but then we
say well look we're very critical of the
mainstream press I began 30 years ago in
the Village Voice writing press
criticism I've done a lot of it and in
fact we say you know if the book really
begins after Watergate when the press
was at its high esteem you know the
Woodward Bernstein and all this stuff
and you know they toppled Nixon and then
we say at that point in America doing
there was a spirit rare really things
might change I'm in the middle 70s
people really thought there could be a
different place and part of what
happened the press the corporate
mainstream press mean in the Washington
Post New York Times they saw it then as
a period of reconsolidation people
shouldn't go too far in fact the late
Katharine Graham gave a speech to the
Publishers Association in the late about
76 saying you know enough already that
it was basically addressed to a lot of
journalists don't get too many ideas
about changing the system here don't
think you can tear down corporations the
way you've tore down the Nixon White
House and don't think we want to go on
tearing down the White House it was a
call you know basically it was waving a
finger and so that's we Chronicle a good
deal of that in the first half of the
book and then we go on you know through
and we take some real case instances
another benchmark I think in the decline
we attach great importance to it and in
fact Jeffrey and I did this book White
Hart
it starts with Gary Webb the late Gary
Webb who wrote for the San Jose Mercury
News and in the middle 90s about the
complicity of the CIA in the importation
of cocaine into them into this country
and where of course did this famous
series in the San Jose Mercury News in
the middle 90s that the big fuss had
been in the late 80s about this they've
been hearings conducted by Senator John
Kerry on by the late nineties it was
kind of a semi forgotten story that the
shuttle of arms and cocaine and of
course of ultimately it exploded with
the iran-contra
scandal in the late 80s which was very
discomforting to the Reagan
administration well where produced this
journalism and then it wasn't going
anywhere but then black radio took it up
and they were saying how here are
inner-city neighborhoods completely
trashed out by crack cocaine and here's
it turns out the CIA was involved at
that point I think it was seen as
destabilizing to the system one of the
points we make in the book is that the
mainstream press is very protective of
course and part of the corporate system
the political system and they went after
Webb The New York Times The Washington
Post the LA Times conspicuously and they
trashed him viciously and unfairly and I
drove them from his job and in a way
ultimately it's what I think drove them
to his death because he so I didn't kill
himself you know a very tragic story but
of course it turned out when you look at
the CIA Inspector General's reports
which we detail in this book we quote
from them that Webb was right Webb got
it right the mainstream press got it
wrong that's and then the last bit of
the book just to finish the on the book
is we say we call it counterpunches
start of the story this is journalism
that we think great stuff that we did
which the mainstream press didn't get
because we think now this is a time of
real opportunity the table has been
leveled when I came to America you know
these vast newspaper combines the New
York Times you put it on the scale today
and was it weigh five pounds or
something but on the Internet you know
it's as high as your laptop screen same
as counterpunch
so the playing field has been leveled in
a way I may not go on being level but
this is the time you know the left is
always kind of down in the mud and
depressed about things generally
pessimistic we say don't be so
pessimistic cut a punch which is a huge
audience we have like three million hits
a day we have a hundred thousand unique
viewers a day it's big stopped in fact
you write a lot about optimism and the
need for optimism I tend to be a bushy
tailed I mean I don't think we I don't
think you can persuade people of much if
you're always down in the mud if you're
always saying is as fascism is around
the left has a terrible propensity to
say you know fascism is around the
corner it's all getting worse and worse
well I mean yes the you know the present
regime has trashed the Constitution the
bill
right the Patriot Act all that stuff
there's plenty to complain about but you
know you never get too far just by
whining ident people don't like whiners
I don't like whiners you call Rupert
Murdoch in this book a world scale
monster why I think every word carries
its weight and does its duty I mean
first of all his world scale I knew
Murdoch a little bit when he had briefly
held the voice I mean he's a ruthless
fellow he's a predator so to speak at
every level I think his force in the
world has been maligned I mean he's a
sort of coagulated blob of prejudice and
spleen I didn't know him from from day
one I mean he stands for a posture in
the world which is negative he's raised
the sort of the vulgarity level in this
country very considerably in England
it's a nightmare you know I mean I don't
see how anyone could live within sonic
range of or visual range of a Murdoch
product in England I mean it's like
having us that you know having to carry
some huge bag of sewage change to your
foot I mean the English papers are
pretty impossible anyway but I'm here
you know the his presence I think is
almost uniformly negative and has been
negative did you compare even for
someone like William Randolph Hearst in
an earlier era and Hearst was no angel
he was in many ways a terrible thug but
I no I think he it was a slightly more
if you had to balance the two I think
the scales would tilt in favor of Hearst
very easily
well continuing on us I'll make one more
point about knowledge
I think he's basically he Hawks his
political services through his media to
the political part that he sees as
providing him with commercial and
political advantage that's a point that
was very well made in a book by a friend
of mine Bruce page published in England
about about Murdoch you know so he goes
with Thatcher he goes with Blair it was
with Bush if he sees that the Democrats
going to win you know then his papers
you know whoever it might be you know
Clinton Hillary Clinton I think he was
in favor of her being the Democratic
nominee the bargains are always ahead
continuing your imagery of sewage you
call journalism schools in this book
feed lot of mediocrity feed lots of
mediocrity we'll chosen Frick I think um
the point about Jay schools I think and
also I noticed if you go to a campus
where there's a J school the newspaper
campus newspaper is very often not so
good why come because the kids are all
already writing for their employer
employees their clips you know sort of I
think very often written so that when
they'll hand them to the hiring editor
of the New York Times or one of the big
papers although this is going to be
changing to show that they're already
respectable you know you know balance
and all you know everything and you're
not not too far up not radical and so
it's essentially a process of selection
I mean when I went into journalism you
know went to a paper that you are still
a lot of sort of okay was a more
bohemian outfit you know you had strange
people who come into journalism late but
now it's credentials you go into a
newspaper office now it's like going
into an insurance office you know
solemnly attendant under things they're
very respectable people and it's way to
respect and the J schools got a lot to
do with that I mean I don't know what
they learn in these J schools for two
years I mean how to build a story and
how to do this and how to do that I mean
I'm certainly you know tried to help
people get into these various grad
schools but I always wag my finger at
them and tell them why don't you just
get around the world and settle in some
country that's you know they say how can
I get ahead and I say well settle in a
country where they're going to be a war
in about three years which you know you
can set your watch by how many wars
there are you know they go on and on and
then suddenly you'll be the stringer now
the newspapers or the what are the radio
they're desperate to have expertise from
wherever it is the time my brother
Patrick got going in Lebanon in the
middle seventy you know suddenly he was
the guy you know he's not have to like
parachuting a new person if it's the
brother that's currently in Iraq yeah
he's been in Iraq probably more than
anybody else but it easy
continuing with the journalism I want to
read back to you something that you
wrote recently really concerning about
the current war you say sometimes I
dream of them Friedman and Tom Friedman
Hitchens Christopher Hitchens and Berman
is firm in poll boom a Paul Berman like
characters in a Beckett play
buried up to their necks in a rubbish
dump on the edge of bag
at reciting their columns to each other
as the local women turn over the corpses
to see if one of them is her husband or
her son yeah that I read that last week
actually just after the anniversary of
the war and I went back and I didn't
have to go back so I can remember it
well enough but all these people who
made all these predictions and
encouragement in the journalism area for
the war like starting with freedmen you
know one of the most pompous people on
the planet who has got what three
turrets surprises I mean oh what a
disgrace to the profession can call it
that they should decorate this nitwit
with three two letters and then the
hitchens of course was totally pro war
and a cheerleader to the war still says
he thought it was a you know he was
right to have said that I went to the
Bush White House right before the
outbreak of the war in the spring of
2003 to give us some you know pep talk
this is a journalist you know on board
totally and then Berman you know what
he's not so interesting but under others
and when you look at how wrong they were
about everything but then you see and I
the piece that you quote from I quote a
lot of my brother stuff now Patrick has
really been in Iraq probably more than
any other journalist as a non embedded
journalist he's gone over Iraq he's
pointed out constantly that a lot cannot
be reported I could it is to lethally
dangerous but he goes on these roads and
he's you know he's very experienced he
says when you look at this absolutely
shattered country you know where five
six thousand people a month are being
slaughtered in these what these these
you know well in the war by do by the
various forces the factionalism just
blown up destroyed you've got of course
the troops over there many of them you
know forced to stay on the stop-loss
business you know you know coming back
dead and of their bodies coming back or
coming back maimed but be psychic and
physical wreckage in America for years
to come because you know there's a
percentage that have PTSD and you know
and all the problems associated with
that and you just think I'm no fan of
Saddam Hussein I think he was a monster
I think he you know he got his I think
I say in that piece you know he he
destroyed his country and then basically
the United States but that invasion
carried it off to the moon I'm in
plundering it while it did so for the
oil and the rest of it it's an absolute
disaster you can go from Bad which is
what Iraq was I mean partially destroyed
by the Clinton era sanctions by the way
which people constantly forget the
Liberals or board for sanctions although
they and then you've got from 2003 to
2007 this country is gone and people's
lives irretrievably I mean millions of
lives destroyed it would have been
better if they had not gone in so my I
said I'd like these people to be in
Baghdad you know having to answer a few
very serious questions from these poor
women and family people constantly
searching for you know they're wrong so
I think we say at the end of that piece
it was the people accused of being the
hard left or the left and also the
libertarians we should not forget the
libertarians people like on anti-war
calm you know who were against the war
clearly and said this is a terrible idea
some people are very vocal against you
in fact some of your old colleagues Eric
Alterman said if Alexander Coburn
weren't published in the nation he would
be considered a crank beyond the limits
of intelligent discourse Norman
Podhoretz says that Coburn's weekly
pieces have set a new standard for
better journalism in this country and
actually you put that quote on the back
of your own book proud of it proud of it
why well I wouldn't want Norman
Podhoretz specific positions a fine an
intelligent guy because Norman Podhoretz
you know the founding neocon the former
editorial commentary you know he's he
spawned literally and in his extended
family advised by blood or by infacility
is one of the neocons to be praised by
Norman Podhoretz it'd be a terrible load
to carry
I mean nota Minister it's an
insignificant figure who like he's
called me Lana he's called me Hitler
he's called me ropes via a new day a new
name John Margolis in 1998's says as an
accuser Joe McCarthy is more responsible
I did another one yeah Jack Sheaffer in
1995 said if you've ever handled a
venomous snake you already know what
it's like to
chat with Alexander Coburn John sharifa
he's going to he's not a bad fellow and
George will said Alexander Coburn should
be put into the Smithsonian Museum as
the last Stalinist alongside of Stalin I
don't know why they what does that mean
I don't know I think there's a number of
things you can say in America that I
meant to say don't ever listen to this
guy so you can say you're a Stalinist
which I'm not I think spelling is a
terrible fellow a monster a mass
murderer but if you say that you know
then that's meant to put you on the
defensive I mean if anyone should be in
the Smithsonian to tell George actually
oh think no man okay I think the cases
all burnished up and that's little brass
plate but or you can say you're an
anti-semite that's another one people
they're all an anti-semite don't listen
to him that means basically if you've
ever said a word of criticism of the
State of Israel
you're classified as an anti-semite it's
a in fact I think an Israeli ambassador
was once after if they've been to the
States what do you can't as one of your
bigger tremont achievements here he said
to persuade Americans that to criticize
Israel was to be anti-semitic well it's
not true we did in fact did a book I
have it right here you have not read the
politics of anti-semitism yeah series of
essays place eval it's about exactly
what I've been saying that we say you
know there's many things you can
criticize State of Israel for you know
I'm starting with the treatment of
Palestinians and a number of people
address this issue from a number of
perspectives that I have an essay in
there about it and it was actually a
very it was the first kind of punch book
we did and it was a big success but I
think that's changing now because you
know the lobbyists the israel lobby has
received a ferry much much more public
criticism than it has in recent years
starting with of course former President
Carter's book and also the professor's
water mere himer of Chicago and
Princeton did a
explicit and carefully researched of
salt on the lobby and that 20 years ago
you wouldn't have seen that it was a
very different atmosphere so that that's
what that's about but to go back to
himselves so
you do know just in my somebody by
saying you know I don't know of course I
suppose you could say they sleep with
beasts or something but that's kind of
out of date now but so it's a Stalinist
an anti-semite or whatever it hasn't got
any connection with who I am or what I
do but it's you know it's a quick way of
testing a bit of mud over the fence
Alexander Coburn is our guest for
in-depth this month and we would now
invite you to join us for Democrats
here's your phone line - OH - 737 triple
zero one for Republicans - OH - 737
triple zero - for independence - OH -
six two eight zero two zero five and of
course you can also join us by email
which is book TV at c-span org you wrote
recently that if Hillary Clinton and
Laura Bush were running for the
presidency you would vote for Laura Bush
I would I think I like mrs. Bush I think
I mean I always think she's one of the
fuse of like elements of restraint upon
her husband I mean I think she but Laura
Bush I believe was a was a wizard
Democrat really when she met her husband
in Texas I was thought her personal
statement or rather reasonable I think
if you believe would would she has some
line in one of the Woodward books that
she was opposed to the war I think it's
uh the role of the first lady I mean you
know they would give them some
assignment like Nancy Reagan used to
Russia run saying no to drugs or
whatever and yes to astrology
and you know and they all have a sort of
public assignment but I think a lot of
me you know hold hold the old the old
man down and I think mrs. Bush I think
has been a force for good whereas I I'm
not a great fan of mrs. Clinton I say I
think I think the moment you know every
administration when it comes in has a
period when they can do something and
the Clinton people got in in in 92 and
that I think health reform single-payer
a change in that system was possible at
that moment and they messed up those
first three months disastrously
you know buddy what by late spring 93 it
was all over then they were hauling in
you know Republicans to tell them how to
run the place and it was gone you know
as quickly as that it was gone and and
Clinton put in mrs. Clinton to run the
health thing and and she she came up
with an unholy mess a terrible
compromise that was meant in that that
the insurance industry somewhat of the
hook no one could understand it was it
was that was it it was all over now and
that was an opportunity which was a
terrible loss beyond that she never said
anything I think it's particularly
estimable she's now of course trying to
prove that you know she's you know could
make war as well as as well as the next
guy you know and you know all options
are on the table with Iran and she
doesn't want to even in this you know I
think rather unconvincing plan put up by
the Democrats in the hill she's talking
about a permanent presence in Iraq of
troops
you know her business dealings but I'm
it's a long way away now back in pre
Clinton White House weren't particularly
fragrant in when she was a lawyer for
their whatever that outfit was done in
done in Arkansas tell no fan is there
any any Democrat or any candidate out
there that you are looking towards for
the next presidency well I mean of the
present bunch I had some critical things
about a bomber when he was you know last
year in the Nation magazine on on our
website when he was oh I didn't know he
was a you know cheerleading for Joe
Lieberman who I probably my least
favorite senator we could go to some
nice lead movement let's not rock the
boat but we can rock it but I'm why
waste the time but I mean I'm kind of
feel sorry for Obama now because what
are you advertising is what you must do
and say to to survive in the Democratic
Party so of course you know any
semblance of an interesting position on
the Middle East is vanished he went off
to the AIPAC convention and basically
you know you went in and down sang and
sang the right tunes and you know even
then they said did he sing loud enough
you know I are we quite sure to be yet
get the message and you feel sorry for
the guy because the pressures you know
on anyone running for the presidency you
know the number of homage 'as you have
to make to prove that you're not really
going to be a danger to the status quo
so prove that you never really had an
interesting idea about anything to prove
that you're not going to destabilize you
know the various lobbies which can't the
money you have to raise is so prodigious
now it's going to be over in February
because the Clintons want a front-end
load it said there's no real challenge
you tell no one's ever going to emotion
this system you know with there's so
many i/o user out there I mean I
supported Ralph Nader I mean I was
stopped sympathy and support for Ralph
Nader in 2000 and 2004 because he said
you know there has to be another voice
didn't you say you thought that he got a
bum rap in the 2004 do I know I think he
got a lot of bum raps first of all you
know even today someone was telling me
that Ralph's this film about Ralph
that's going around that Oh sometime
they wouldn't the dump it they wouldn't
they couldn't show it somewhere because
the Democrats still hold to the year
2000 against him because somehow Ralph
was meant to be responsible for all the
mess that Al Gore made of his candidacy
my bleep mouth Nader why not blame Al
Gore while you're at it you know and so
I think Ralph we know one of the most
honorable careers available for
inspection in America today and
political and social terms a guy who
really made a difference has got you
know very often sort of driven out of
the system I mean in 2004 Nader told me
told us it kind of punched it I think
the Democrats were trying to obstruct
his candidacy in like 25 different
courtrooms I mean they were spending a
bundle of money now I don't know if
there'll be any third party challenger
in 2008 what did we got we got Edwards
Clinton and Obama I guess of those three
Edwards is the one who's talking to some
kind of economic populism so I guess our
sympathies might go to Edwards I take
some phone calls for you first up is
Clark New Jersey Democrat line I good
afternoon mr. Cobra appointed to you
what my question is really about the
future of the left-wing media and its
impact on potential candidates so let me
just make a quick preference
I just think it's interesting that in
America people like you and say Barbara
Ehrenreich are defined as the left
whereas you know in Europe you would be
pretty much within the center left like
you would be a social democrat and what
I think needs to happen is we have
public intellectuals that are bringing
the ideas that are being talked about in
academia talking about scholars like
like Slava you Jack Antonio Negri a
David Harvey people that are really
talking about progressive left-wing
discourse and we need to bring that into
the public sphere and I think people
like you should be talking about that
should be bringing this to regular
people well so you welcome we should be
conveyer belts for for interesting minds
like Z Zac I don't like some of these
acts Sommers is like I can't understand
who like needs act sees that because
this uh he's kind of a he's he's a what
is he I think it's a Croatian originally
he's a big lefty thinker I mean I find
him a little impenetrable to be honest
to you David Harvey is a very
interesting writer he's I think English
who's done big critiques of
neoliberalism very interesting fellow
Tony
Negri did a book called Empire which I
can't make too much headway with but I
think the caller's point was that would
I be a social democrat in Europe mm-hmm
well Social Democrats like being slapped
across the face for those so dead fish I
always think I mean I made Social
Democrat in England that means the
Labour Party no I think the Labour Party
under Tony Blair is not terrible in
France I don't know what it means so I
don't know what social democrat is but
beyond that is there a world out there
of left-wing academic thinkers that we
should be preferring well in
counterpunch we do it every day we get a
lot of people who write for us who are
left-wing people in the academies you
know in there on tenure track or there
comfortably under the umbrella of tenure
and they got plenty of time to write I
think that it depends on the area I I
was just think saying to Geoffrey the
other day or were you saying to me that
you know left-wing economists we would
love to publish lots of left-wing
economists there are people like Robert
Pollin up there
in Amherst and a few others but we don't
get them what we do get as one of our
main and most popular contributors is
Paul Craig Roberts former number two in
the Reagan Treasury who is anti-war and
very vigorous critic and also a
tremendous critic of you know the
assaults on constitutional freedoms and
the Bill of Rights and is also a
relentless critic of what's really
happened to jobs in America around the
bush
he writes very clearly we don't print
things that Craig some other areas that
Craig we have rather different views
from Craig on pinochet for example but
we don't publish that but he writes
clear accessible prose one of the
problems with left-wing academic writing
is it's not always the easiest thing in
the world to read you know people they
want clear forceful writing we certainly
regard ourselves as a website we don't
think of ourselves as a zine or a blog
we're a daily paper if you like but we
we certainly try to represent the best
of you know minds I think we'd you know
whether there's a guy in New Orleans
who's bill Quigley when we publish all
the time who's fantastic on what really
has happened you know after the
hurricane in New Orleans and he said
he's from Tulane you know I would regard
him as the best of the left there are
many others we publish all the time
Bobby found Florida hello yes good
afternoon anti-semitism is thought of as
the right-wing phenomenon traditionally
however you left-wingers using Israel
struggle for survival as an excuse are
the anti-semites of the last quarter of
the 20th century and on your way in the
21st century well I think good make I'm
in court
I think that's complete nonsense it's
just what I was saying earlier really
Israel's struggle assisters the Bible I
think it'd be Israelis secure I don't
think a struggling for survival I think
people who are struggling a subset of
survival it's protected by the United
States you know I don't see any threat
to Israel's survival it's ludicrous to
say so I do see a threat to survival our
Palestinians who are you know living on
what $1 a day in Gaza is grabbing for
their food or scrap heaps who
driven by the wall away from their
houses their houses are being demolished
you know the ultimate aim I think being
to expel them from Palestine their
ancestral lands millions more unable to
return that's a struggle for survival
yet this fellow can come on the phone
from home sound and say you know we are
the left wing of the anti-semites when
we've got an elementary concern for
human rights I have a follow-up caller
yes well I would love to have finished
it would have been nice to have been
able to finish you make common cause
with Holocaust deniers and all that's
true again I'm not going to have you
saying I'm a Holocaust denier it's
absolutely outrageous no critic of
Israel that I know of and on our website
has ever had anything to do with
Holocaust Mel you're just throwing these
words out as you always do and as your
kind always do just smearing with any
wild charge that you can come up with I
bitterly resent it and I think you have
no right to say it
will you make common cause with holic
well I do not make Holocaust you know I
absolutely not I think it's a libel
identity you should be saying it you
make common cause no I'm not going to
have you saying it you're not I'm not
going to accept that I'm not going to
accept you saying it next caller is from
colo California colo California not yes
it is colo California I'm always
wondering when I hear on Journal people
will call up and they'll say we're so
happy that America's fighting in Iraq so
that they aren't fighting and say Des
Moines um
and we're out there killing people I
always wonder what the Iraqis died I
guess they get to see television
sometimes what did they think when they
hear us Americans say how glad we are
we're fighting over there thank you well
I think there was a period after 2003
when and not when Iraqis genuinely
thought that my life might get better
there was a brief period because I think
there were huge illusions about what
could happen fostered I think many of
the exiled Iraqis who suddenly thought
you'd right into Iraq you know the
flowers would be put in your gun barrels
they would have an election and
everything would be tickety-boo now of
course I think it's now what the latest
poll you asked actually from Coelho
there you asked a question I think which
can be answered with some precision I
think the last poll I think done by an
American polling
it said I think over 70% of Iraqis
actually wanted US troops to leave which
I think gives a precise response which
is a terrible judgement on you know the
intentions and performance of the
invasion of 2003 would there have been
any circumstances that you would have
approved as going into Iraq no I don't
think so I think the illusions you see I
think a lot of liberals came on board
for intervention in the 90s to do with
to do with the Serbia and they there was
so-called benign intervention ISM which
way you think you know this time it's
always it's like the search for mr. good
war I saw the other day someone had it
as a nice phrase they always looking for
the good war I didn't there are any good
wars no just war I don't believe so I
mean you can maybe establish the
theoretical construct war is war and in
the current stage where America is the
great power in the world to say that
America can perform a benign
intervention I think is to show that you
are prey to a thousand different
delusions which we try and dispel on a
daily basis in 2004 you wrote this book
along with Jeffrey Sinclair dimes worth
of difference what was the thesis here
well the dimes worth of difference was
you might have missed between the
Republican and the and the Democratic
parties and it was before the 2004
election how many of the essays you can
reprint every four years for the next I
don't know how long as long as the
present system which I think shows signs
of tremendous decay I mean the political
system is decayed a lot even since you
know I began observing it in the early
70s I mean then look at the convention I
mean we write just to finish our
question it's really about the political
system as it currently exists you wrote
in here the central political issue of
this first decade of the 21st century is
the decay of the American political
system and of the term pride parties
that share the spoils wherever one looks
at the gerrymandered districts the
balloting methods the fundraising
corruption fumes like vapors from a vast
swamp was there ever a time in which it
was it was better and better every era
you know contains you know good things
in them and bad things but I think yes I
think the system at the moment really is
sliding down I mean look
references I mean from the 70s
conventions although in a way they were
already rigged and nothing much that
mean they were a sense of a political
conversation a convocation of a party I
mean a convention should be if you're
thinking of a party is the expression of
people who've joined a party for a
social political purpose at the
convention you get together and you
figure out policy you mandate your
political representatives to go and
execute that policy if they win the
election well in the 70s I remember the
first convention I went to was
McGovern's down in Miami in 72 and of
course famously he didn't even get to
make his acceptance speech till 3:00 in
the morning and all the pundits in the
committee that said this showed the
disintegration of discipline and we
bring back the age of the party boss
journalists always incredibly
conservative yeah that was your first
year in the United States right yeah and
then so actually it was a sign of great
ferment that people in Miami the
Democrats they were debating or trying
to debate real policy
Iwan one of my neighbors in petróleo is
Peter Hannaford who wrote speeches for
Ronald Reagan for years Hannaford and
diva and I said to Peter we get along
fine I said to him do you ever recall a
convention in recent memory where there
was a really an issue which was debated
and where the issue hung in the balance
and nobody knew which way we'd go and it
was a genuine expression of debate and
difference he said and I was there I
remember it Kansas City when the
Reaganites that was when Reagan was
challenging forward for the nomination
in 76 would it have been someone's going
to ring up and say I'm wrong but oh and
there was a debate over can the
Republican Party should dispose a moral
foreign policy this was seen by the
fourth port forces an attack on
Kissinger the conjunction and the idea
being morality and Kissinger didn't have
much to do with each other and which is
true in many ways and it was an attack
on day taunt an attack on policy and
there was a real debate and Peter told
me that I'd forgotten this but it came
down to a voice the people running the
show they said to the Reagan people you
can have a debate but you're not going
to have any counted votes we're not
going to have that we can have a voice
and they won on the
and Peter said you try and find that
resolution in recorded form anywhere but
now look at that in those days in the
70s you could go and you go in and the
bid there would be the three networks
with their boobs you know Walter
Cronkite and Chancellor and rebel is
doing the ABC one and you know it was it
was like a three day four day event I
mean what will there be lucky these days
if first of all the convention is
totally scripted I mean I don't know why
they're bothered to have delegates just
have cardboard with faces painted on
them you know in the chairs and then
it'll be down to what three hours on
network television you'll probably show
a whole bunch of it here on seascape of
the gavel gavel to gavel should we if I
think you an art well I mean you should
have some present political activity if
of course it's you know twenty eight
scripted speeches which all of which are
written by the speech writers for the
candidate I mean after it'll get a
little tedious
unless complete junkies and all you're
the junkie commentators who make the
simulacrum that something genuinely
politically interesting is happening
it's a sort of a part same way that the
network boots our inner networks are now
all under those networks are under
severe challenge then you survive
because of what prescription ads these
days Boston Massachusetts hello oh hi
yeah I'm trying to glad to see that
c-span isn't giving Alexander Coburn but
David Irving treatment my question for
mr. Coburn is about an article that
appeared on and sent a punch a couple of
weeks ago by Christopher Ketchum the
details Israeli involvement on 9/11 and
its subsequent suppression perhaps you
think there's more to 9/11 than most of
us and I think that probably is could
you perhaps expand on it thanks for well
yeah we published an article by Chris
Ketchum a long special issue which was
about it starts with the a well-known
recorded event which was the arrest of
some Israelis in a van on the New Jersey
Shore on the morning of 9/11 and they
were cheering and they were excited
suspicions there was a police bulletin
which is Christopher
Ketchum begins his piece with and it
turns out they way as well is they were
they were arrested and spent 71 days in
prison they were two of them so was
established by the Jewish forward later
worked for the Mossad and Ketchum goes
through that and discusses with
quotations and very good reporting what
they were doing were they Mossad agents
who had been subcontracted by the CIA
because they were actually good Arabs
because to follow the the hijackers then
there was some you know their presence
and then he links this with there was a
famous thing called the Israeli art
students which was a better number of
articles have been written about him
actually and kept them included for
Salon originally showing how there were
these groups of so-called art students
selling art stuff who seemed to be
constantly going near federal facilities
DEA offices and the like this is again
recorded in the matter of you know
record and it turns out that they've
been in areas like Hollywood Florida
where the hijackers had been so it's not
the Ketchum is saying you know that you
know somehow Israel was you know
responsible for their planes hitting the
towers but what did what did what were
they trying to find out it's been
contested ly true that there was a
presence there for Mossad who under
whose auspices were they working at what
stage did they know what did they tell
the US government didn't they tell the
US government that's what that piece is
about and are their answers not
definitive ones I mean he suggests no
there are no definitive answers I should
say that we are not a counterpunch
people who believe you know that neither
has held 9/11 conspiracies 'um which
were not part of and indeed of you know
that somehow via 9/11 was an inside job
and all the rest of it we don't believe
that and when Dad and we published
indeed lengthy attacks on that position
but we thought that the 9/11 and the
role of these people in that band and so
forth is was a serious journalistic
topic and Ketchum does it in a very
responsible where people want to read it
they can go to our website and get hold
of it Cleveland Ohio hello yes Alexander
it's a pleasure to speak with you sir
two questions the first question
the humor guy and me if Bush and Putin
or playing chess who would you put your
money on second question I know I made
you laugh Thank You second question as a
blogger myself and I find a and I'm
really deep into the energy issues of
global oil production etc etc all of us
bloggers out here seem to have access to
terrific websites other links and we're
all chattering at the same time my
dilemma is this with all the credible
data that's out there why do we
continually be either labeled the fringe
element or minimized by our local
political pundits ie
newspapers as you were speaking before
you're in the mainstream and what can we
collectively do to kind of react that
and I would implore you please to go to
Stormin Norman to get a taste of what
I'm fighting you're in Cleveland Ohio
being number one in poverty the ranked
number seven is the melissad is one of
the most dangerous cities in Cleveland
and I look forward to your comments
about the chest pet have a good day I
should say you're from Cleveland and
well start with your chest question I
don't know I'm chess I died cause I'd
bet on Tooting I'd think he'd probably
placed yes I've never seen any mention
that the president United States plays
chess so I guess we have to give it to
Putin on that one that's for this
business about the blogosphere it's true
how's that I noticed that the mainstream
paper's like the let's say howard kurtz
in the Washington Post
he'll refer to the blogosphere and then
he'll pick up a couple of you know
individual bloggers and it is always a
sense slightly of a fringe now there are
very big political websites I mean
there's you know I don't think howard
kurtz as ever
so far as I know ever referred to
counterpunch org I wonder if he's ever
referred to anti-war calm I can't say
maybe he has maybe he hasn't in other
words there are substantial presences
you know where we reach an audience
after all you know a lot of people every
day you know what I said you know well
hips don't mean so much but unique
visitors a hundred thousands a day
across a month you know that really adds
up that is not just I mean with old
respect to bloggers there are hundreds
of bloggers are the thousands millions
of bloggers out there many of which are
very amusing and how can you get to I
think first of all the papers like to in
a way recognize the blogosphere to show
that they're kind of with it and also
this is the trend in events on the other
hand they always want to give the
impression that it's Norman the nerd in
the basement you know knocking away into
the computer it's not quite like that
now how can the bloggers collectively
you know arouse in a mighty blog storm a
blood storm perfect blog storm that
would show their presence well that
raises questions on what is the
political power of the Internet you know
there are collective organizations like
moveon.org you know which are taken very
seriously a New York Review of Books has
written pieces about them and they are
they are a presence do they lead to
effective political action I mean an
interesting example which we just
commented on recently was you know when
the Congress was coming up to its votes
you know on cutting off the war in Iraq
you know move on is really an extension
of the Democratic Party so when they
were saying it's like a parody of I
write a parody at the beginning of end
times abut as it then was macneil-lehrer
mm-hm
when I say that in the 70s
macneil-lehrer in the middle 70s coming
on to give the illusion of choices which
were always conservative and I did three
parodies on the crucifixion on
cannibalism and slavery where I had it
as these issues had debated by
macneil-lehrer so on cannibalism the
debate wouldn't be presented as you know
on the one had it's great to eat human
meat on the other hand it's wrong to eat
human meat it would be - between human
meat being great and regulating
consumption of human meat or slavery you
can be Pro slave but you wouldn't be
anti slavery you would be four regulated
slavery you know you say you'd have a
manacle on one foot not the other you
know only one beating a week under
federal regulatory auspices that was my
effort to show that what passes for the
presentation of options in the public
official sphere are very often not
options at all and of course right-wing
radio says you know and now from the
extreme left Senator Edward Kennedy
adil candy is not from the extreme left
he's a mainstream liberal so the idea is
constantly to edge the conversation
right and right so now you're looking at
you know all these shows like mark
shields you know all impeccable
mainstream liberals and not mark
shielding I won't do that but presenting
these people as lefties or radicals
they're not they're all part of the same
large stable here had it how did we get
to that point oh it happened it happened
through about 30 years I mean I think at
the end of the 60s America was there was
a lot of radicalism abroad in America
people genuinely thought the system
could be changed even in the early 70s
senator former Senator Jim a Burress of
of South Dakota great man who was a
one-term senator in the 70s said to me
you know in he put up a bill in the US
Senate to horizontally and vertically
divesting the oil companies that mean if
you were if you had an oil well you
couldn't own a coal mine if you had an
oil refinery you couldn't own gas pumps
so that in other words was breaking up
the oil companies on its first reading
in the US Senate is paled by three votes
now that doesn't mean it was going to go
through but it meant um if you put up
the US Senate today to break up the oil
companies even though a lot of people
out there paying three dollars and
change at the gas pump would love to
break up the oil companies they think
that they're you know Exxon and the rest
of them and you know gouging the
consumer largest profits in their
history but it isn't even on the board
if you put up in the US Senate to break
up the oil companies and I could be
wrong maybe some great senator has I
think it'd be cut it off in in a
straitjacket so that's move to the right
a lot of there were ideas for public
power in the middle seventies you know I
mean people still struggle for you know
municipal power you know and public
ownership throughout areas like
Sacramento where you have municipal
power Dennis Kucinich of Ohio you know
in 76 you know he tried to protect the
local utility the publicly owned utility
and the business interests turned
against him and he was product was in
the political wilderness he fought a
great fight and it took him 20 years to
get back in of course I should have
mentioned him as a as a as a I think
is officially running I wish him wasn't
because his real last time I think it's
a very good congressman and he's doing
great stuff but of course if he gets
going politically as the lefty and what
happened in in in 2004 is he got as far
as Boston and then said to everybody
well I'm not going to make it so vote
for a guy who stands for everything I've
been pretty in baying and protesting
against and he just was a good soldier
for the Democratic Party so I think this
time people remember that and say Dennis
in 2008 you're going to be saying the
same thing and you're going to be all
saying to vote for some candidate like
Hillary Clinton who says we should have
a permanent true present presence in
Iraq but mister the political center of
gravity in the country at least as
regimented and regulated by the
mainstream press and by TV has yes
indeed moved very much to the right is
it Hoek on Washington
it's Hoquiam watch aqueon thank you very
much please go ahead yeah yeah hi Alex
this is one of your [ __ ] come
friends out here in Washington first I
want to thank c-span for for putting
Alexander Coburn on I mean it's a real
comment on their society that the only
place we can see Alexander Coburn on
television is c-span Alex could you
would you talk about the role of
religion in politics and and do you
think that it that anyone in either of
the two major parties could be elected
president who doesn't owe and scrape to
the to the religious right oh well other
what I say is going to be totally
welcome to you because I think the left
I frequently think the left worry too
much about fundamentalism of religious
fundamentalism and they you know they go
on and on there's a sort of industry in
exposing the right wing the right wing
religious people I mean half the time I
say just wait they'll catch them in a
whorehouse dinner or later like Swaggart
you know and down they go I don't I
don't get that made because I grew up in
Ireland I'm not a Catholic but I grew up
in a profoundly religious country
20 40 years ago in Ireland the Catholic
hierarchy ruled everything they said
that you know you couldn't kissing
wasn't permitted on-screen when I was a
little boy
went to the movies you thought that the
human when people kiss you know their
faces would come to within a foot of
each other and then spring apart and
that's how it was done you know probably
the same in Kansas where you came from
but because the Catholic Center you
wouldn't there's no kissing there was
nothing you know of course no no one
whether you're Protestant or Catholic no
contraception available the the young
woman got knocked up outside marriage
you had to go and live in England or
Boston you leave the village here we are
40 years later all changed all changed
everything changed around so I kind of
not again on the left people think you
know and of course there are right-wing
bigots you know and the Christian
Zionists who are you know among the
worst of the lot when it comes to you
know thinking of course they want you
know to they have an agenda beyond
they're forming common cause with the
Jewish Zionists as regards Israel to get
rid of the Palestinians but of course
they don't really save publicly that in
the end when it comes to the rapture I
think it's the Christians go up and the
juice day down below that it's have
advertised that fit so I think I was
very influenced by something that
happened in the Clinton era which was
wake up now wake oh there were these
Branch Davidians in Texas outside Waco
and korish and the Bureau of Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms wanted to make a
little publicity as probably just before
their budget was coming up for renewal
and they provoked a fight with the
Branch Davidians which ended up with
Janet Reno a Democrat Attorney General
Democratic Attorney General and Clinton
approving the final assault which led to
the incineration burning to death of you
know 83 or 84 people including several
children burned alive why because they
were called a cult that word cult once
you're a cult in America you better
watch out they can kill you the feds
will come in and the liberal press and
the mainstream press said Balian mayor
they had it coming to them too badly and
maybe the kids didn't have much to do
with it their alleged orgies they
alleged it all turned out to be not true
over 80 innocent people you know we're
conducting their lives according to
their life were slaughtered in the most
horrible fashion because the prejudice
against a cult
with total I mean there was a good
example just the other day in Iraq which
my brother Patrick I think exclusively
said there was a cult people identified
as being in the cult were were killed by
US troops in Iraq and it was over 200
people it turned out it was all a
ghastly you know these people had come
up to a guard post they've been
suspicion and then they were blown away
but as soon as you see the word cult I
don't think anyone in America thinks
twice about it so I'm very cautious
about saying you know if people I think
the fundamental people and I have
Christian fundamentalist friends who
think very often if they got too
involved with politics once you start
getting involved with politics
particularly at the beginning when they
were trying to Bush had these programs
to which you wanted to get supervised by
a religious body of course religious
bodies have an agenda that's why they're
religious they have a morality they want
to extend and I think once they
compromise with the feds they're getting
a huge mess I think basically if you
read if you read left sites the
Christians are all powerful the enemy
you know they're dominating everything
if you read the Christian new service or
one of these things they think they're
almost totally impotent and the secular
world is advancing upon their tiny
fortifications inexorably and they're
probably more right than the other crowd
so I'm sorry for my pal in Washington
but I it's not something that gets me
going the Nation magazine does very well
idle scaremongering about but the
right-wing Christian groups the Center
for what's it that one done have done
very magical no the fellow down in
Alabama and I've forgotten the name of
the outfit now southern yeah Southern
Poverty Law Center you published a piece
about them years ago in kind of fun
saying you know it's scare mongering for
elderly people you know secular people
or elderly people elderly Jewish people
across America saying if you don't send
us 10 bucks or 20 bucks the brown shirts
will be marching down your Main Street
tomorrow
send check now you know I don't think
it's quite like that it's it's it's a
racket a lot of it okay to calls and
take a break next call is from San
Francisco good morning I want to commend
c-span for having a telephone number for
independence
a small victory for us that don't bind
to the duopoly I would say that I
supported Native the last two elections
like mr. Coburn and I have followed his
article very carefully I want to mention
that this morning I heard Carl Estabrook
and Paul moot Mewis who have a website
called news from Neptune mentioned that
L that Ralph Nader may be promoting Al
Gore to run as an independent and I
wonder what mr. Coburn thoughts are
about that personally I wish he would
work with Cynthia McKinney on a possible
independent campaign for 2008 thank San
Francisco before before you answer that
I should show our viewers in 2000 you
wrote this book Al Gore a user's manual
yeah which was not friendly to to to
senator Gore Vice President Gore I
should say a bigger fun no I don't know
who is if if Nader is endorsing Gore III
that book it showed what is the history
of the Clinton administration and what
God did within it which was nothing
particularly good by the way he was
calling you know quite eagerly I think
for the invasion of Iraq back in 1998 as
many Democrats were at that time and I
don't agree with I have brother
heterodox views on global warming I'm
not if the weather is getting warmer
I don't think human agency has anything
to do with it I mean I do not believe if
we don't eat ice cream which needs dry
ice which needs co2 that will be
improving the weather chances as a
planet I think the science of global
warming and my poor co-editor Jeffrey
will be dying a million deaths when he
hears me saying this but I that's what I
feel so I'm no fan of Gore's movie
I mean I think the movie and I think a
lot of global warming is just no
shilling for the nuclear power industry
frankly so that's it on sown a dead
Ralph don't do it stop Camden New Jersey
yeah hi am i you through here yep
following so you're on okay I'm on mr. :
I'm having some difficulties here you're
obviously very intellectual and kind of
disturbing to find your Telegraph see
how your what your agenda really leaves
you with that color but about half hour
ago who spoke about Israel and you said
something about your kind
that kind of Telegraph's how you really
feel and this kind of an insulting
remark and your kind what is real kind
your kind your kind meant the [ __ ]
nodded I think you're trying to
insinuate that I meant Jewish or
something your kind other people who go
out saying that any critic of Israel is
an anti-semite who suddenly start
linking your name with people who deny
the Holocaust there are people who do
that I think they do it for completely
cynical reasons mostly I'm there may be
some but completely wrongheaded person
who genuinely believed there's not a
shred of evidence at all for it and I so
I do I get exorcised about it I think
it's absolutely outrageous slur and so I
when I say you're kind that's what I'm
talking about what do you say to that
captain O'Berry pardon go ahead yeah my
problem is that when someone is so
one-sided against Israel then there is
there is some justice for people I know
I decided against Israel I mean in fact
the people that you well were the people
I should say one thing if you go to our
website you consistently read people who
are not sitting in Petrolia California
or in Oregon City which is where Jeffrey
Sinclair's from or Camden New Jersey
which is where you are so from but
people who are in Israel we published
URI AB nary pretty much every week we
published Jonathan cook pretty much
every week we published Gideon Levy we
published people who write for Haaretz
so what you're seeing on our website is
people in Israel who are writing from
them both Jews and Palestinians who are
writing from there so when we say were
one-sided we're not one-sided we are
presenting issues which don't make it
into the American mainstream that's a
big difference
Camden which makes me the point that
it's in Israel they're both Jews and
Arabs have free voice there are money I
don't have free voice that is something
else again them they don't have free
voice you can mean someone like AB Neri
who is not an Arab Peace ado will point
out that inside Israel and of course by
a hundred times more in the occupied
territories the voices aren't totally
free actually I've nary maybe would say
in Israel itself that the pelicans are
more free but Jonathan cook it's been
shown time and again that it's not a
perfect democracy but one thing most of
the land can
only be owned by Jews that's there's not
a perfect democracy at all and it's
getting worse by the way all the time
with extremists like avid or Lieberman
proposing essentially that make it
conditions almost impossible for Arabs
inside Israel Camden we'll wrap it up go
ahead please it's interesting that you
say Israel's not a perfect democracy
therefore what should we do I mean is it
perfect make it make it set up make it
better make the right choice I believe
the way will be made better is actually
by a secular unified state I don't
actually think that the two nations
theory is going to go very far it is
almost comes down to let's blame the
Jews through everything no there's no
doubt I'm not going to accept that
you've got a so script kind of you're
reading from you're not listening to a
line to half an hour great I believe so
I believe so you're going to say that
we're car there you go to visible I see
so this is how we shut down discussion
right my oceanology so I think the
discussion from my point of view has
been shut down almost as long as I've
been in the United States so when I have
an opportunity here to say what the
issues are to say that you can have a
constructive division of the future of
the Middle East without being
immediately accused as the gentleman
from hope son Florida I never never the
Holocaust no you didn't I think you're
saying that we're extremely anti-israel
you haven't actually said I don't know
what your views are whether you think
everything Israel is doing well or what
I think basically the discussion of
Israel in almost every site in America
is crippled by ignorance and by
prejudice says that therefore the when
people talk about you know the roadmap
to peace the the information that's
available for people even to know is not
there because you cannot have a really a
rational discussion about these issues
in 99 percent of the US press following
up on that and emailer asks what is your
reaction to the Jimmy Carter book people
Jimmy Carter book was very well taken I
think he did a fine job it was amazing I
mean to be honest with you there were a
part I which caused shock shock here in
Israel South Africa you can visit South
African Jews years ago said yes in some
ways the part idea is worse in in the
occupied territories in Israel than it
was in South Africa in some ways I think
it's tremendous that a former president
should have actually
put these things done and I think it was
very interesting that suddenly when the
lobby went after him within seconds a
fairly well respected former president
was accused I think by the way the
critics overplayed their hand suddenly
in a Jimmy Carter was basically you know
an advocate of the concentration camps
literally that was said because he
actually I think intervened in some case
with subject Betty you know that he was
he was in the pay of the Arabs this that
and the other thing I mean he was very
careful actually in a way he was to gave
a rather optimistic description of the
situation in Israel proper not in the
occupied territories but I think it's a
sign that at least that book then partly
by the efforts of his critics went to
number four on I think it went to number
four on Amazon it was really good so
it's a healthy son we're going to take a
short break
come back and take some more phone calls
and introduce our audience to your home
which is where my home is in
petrolia Humboldt County in Northern
California and where is that that is if
you look at the map of the United States
you go to California you look at the
ticket bet that sticks out farthest into
the Pacific Ocean and you put your
pencil point right on that tip Cape
Mendocino that's pretty much where I
live it's about an hour and a half south
of Eureka that is far away from
Washington DC as you can get that's why
you could matter why you I guess but
because looking the other way no yeah
it's pretty far away from and what you
write so much about public policy why do
you live so far from I like the place I
can afford to live there I love the
country the in this day and age you know
you're on the internet you can read or
you know you can read every paper in
Washington DC if you want to you can
read every paper in the world if you
want to I mean it's true I can't get on
my bicycle and drive down if I wanted to
and you know I don't know get my walk up
to the Capitol and try and what you know
talk stuff but you can do everything you
want so now and you can live in
congenial surroundings and do you know
Hmong people you like doing things you
like and that's the way it is I can
afford it too we will be back in just a
few moments with more calls for
Alexander Coburn I basically I'm a
country guy I like
I lived ten years in Lund London I grew
up in arm I live ten years in London I
lived ten years in New York I lived in
Key West for a while and glib various of
Central California and I came up here
and people like you know the days when
you'd said you know rural seclusion the
remote writer you know in his rural
fastness you know coming out wearing us
at a belted moujik shirt like leo
tolstoy it's not really where it's at
you know I mean with modern
communications you can you can wake up
in the morning and read every newspaper
on the planet you know it's it's very
different I mean we have here in
petróleo you know we in the winter we
have power outages and all the rest of
it but you know these days I personally
I don't particularly like living in
cities but so you know much of our DSL
line now you've got every image in the
world too many of them available to you
I you know I can be in San Francisco in
in five hours if I feel like a point of
meetings and fly around so that's where
I'm at in what I do and it's an ideal
circumstance for me I think I cut myself
pretty fortunate I like old I am this is
an old 62 Plymouth Belvedere wagon
driven that across the states a couple
of times
got a 318 wide block in it deep in the
back if you want plenty of room to look
under the hood as long as you keep the
engine tuned I think it's actually less
polluting not to have a correct
catalytic converter my friend Pierre
sprey directed all the catalytic
converter does is create sulfuric acid
which it then sprays all over the
neighborhood after the hydrocarbons pass
over the catalytic converter and then
here this is a this is car from the late
60s Newport 68 Newport two door with a
383 engine in it sex I got here on the
west coast drive it around try not to
get tickets in it but I like to drive
around drive across the country meet
lots of people
modern cars kind of my all cars took the
same these days
we've got no character at all you could
drive thousands of miles in America and
barely see an old car anymore tucked in
behind the wheels of their there are
condors or bird Toyota's few holdouts
still try and support the American auto
industry just go along in your older car
it cost a little bit more in gas maybe
then you haven't spent all the money in
the first place if it works out pretty
good and you feel you're driving along
with something with little character in
it that's done by my friend the artist
Steve Rogers done in high relief about a
terrible massacre basically sponsored by
the United States on the real simple on
the borders of Honduras now the soldiers
doing the massacre and there will be
poor people the peasants carrying the
coffin there's a lot of work by Steve
Rogers around here is one of my favorite
artists I'm here it's the old stable so
built about five years ago or friends of
mine in the valley built and there's
Agnes
17 years old who is a thoroughbred Arab
cross wonderful wonderful horse my
mother bred horses so I've always liked
horses ride Agnes every day and here
she's having a mid-morning snack
one just for commencement this is a
rammed earth building which we call the
silo house which we put up about three
four years ago rammed earth is a very
old technique of ramming earth down I
think like many writers actually I like
thinking about things other than writing
I like to build this is a square
building going into a dome done by my
friend and neighbor Greg Smith this is a
frieze Jasper's very pleases in the
picture the preparation of cider which
Steve Rogers did I think many people
thought this was some kind of outpost of
al-qaeda at one point because it looked
a little like a Middle Eastern mosque
but it's a nice very nice building I
love to build if I had enough money I'd
be like ludwig ii of bavaria i'd never
start building I grew up in Ireland and
there were plenty of towers around
usually Norman keeps in various stages
of ruin there was also the old round
towers there was one in my home village
of Ardmore I've always been kind of
tower oriented so after being here a
while in Petrolia built a tower sort of
tower like anyway out of mostly recycled
redwood and people who donate to
counterpunch all support us we put them
up in the tower and they stay there very
happy up there there's no one around so
the tower is dead in my life I could
shut myself up in the tower I suppose
and emerge after 15 years with a very
important piece of writing but I'm more
social so I stay 300 feet lower down and
talk to the animals and the animals talk
to me your miserable life as a dog want
to give me the first chapter I have been
books about dog seen and written by dogs
my dog chew it wonder nicest books about
a dog ever written
just the heroes secretly writing is
memorise he's going to disclose me the
life of
dictating novels canine exploitation
very good
[Music]
an email for you
I remember reading your column in the
Village Voice many years ago I also
remember that the voice rather abruptly
dropped your column what were the
circumstances oh yeah in 1984 I had a
fellowship from the thing called the
Institute for Arab studies based in
Massachusetts it was an American based
nonprofit my friend the late Edward
Sayid I got a little grant to do some
writing and there was it was New York
was very contentious in those days and
they said they said I was in the pay of
the Arabs and all the rest of it and I
thought that then the voice then edited
by Schneiderman they suspended me and I
thought that was outrageous
and so I left and I went to the nation
and I joined the nation in 84 now I read
someplace that the the nation at one
point in time asked you not to be so
critical one the way you heard that yeah
well is true there was a time when the
time when he was suggested I was too
critical of Clinton mmm-hmm in the early
actually in about 94 or 95 the funny
thing was and they they the editor
suggested they was keen on me a lot of
nation readers thought I was too
critical of Clinton and I think they
were perturbed and they didn't come to
anything because I went on being
critical the funny thing was a lot of
writers who then were critical of
Clinton were then in the nation were
calling for his resignation and his
impeachment because of the Lewinsky
affair and on the Lewinsky affair I was
defending Clinton because I thought you
know I thought the whole thing was
ridiculous you know it was a sort of act
so you had writers like I don't know
Mark Cooper I think of the of the the
nation are thundering their their fury
at Atlin so the tables were reversed but
I thought I still think the whole
Lewinsky thing was completely ridiculous
this email er says I've always been
puzzled as to why the Wall Street
Journal of all places
hired you when was that how long did you
write for them Oh The Wall Street
Journal I did a column in The Wall
Street Journal from 1980 to 1990 and I
was asked by the then editor the late
Bob Bartley and the current chairman and
mighty pooh-bah
Peter can too to do this column they
work and they thought that the readers
of The Wall Street Journal in 80 needed
a little diversity from the stray from
that editorial page which was and
remains this day as far as I'm concerned
insane insane Mad Dog neocon journalism
by and large some exceptions
oddly enough Paul Craig Roberts had been
I think the assistant editorial page
editor I may have that slightly wrong in
a slightly earlier phase and here he is
now ready for kind of punch so they they
had a panel of four I think it was
myself hodding Carter who had just
stopped being the spokesperson for the
State Department during the Iran crisis
where you made his name they had more
kondraki
and I think they had another one whose
name I forget and I was the the left of
the three or the four it varied and it
was a very good place to be I mean it
was a 1200 word column every Thursday on
the top right hand of the editorial
spread and you know it so I whacked away
at Bob Bartley he was funny about it he
said initially there was a tremendous
fuss on the right they said you know
you'd think that the Kremlin had taken
over the Wall Street Journal and he had
to hand out ticket saying you know
certified Soviet agent or whatever it
was they were accusing me of being and I
wrote away there it was a tremendously
good perch to have the most effective
columns were usually every now and again
I'd do an environmental column and go up
to some corporation
I remember Merrell Dow was going to
build a pharmaceutical plant not far
from where I grew up in Ireland and I
did that the appropriate moment I did a
column and the plant was canceled the
next day I think it column had something
to do with it it was the Wall Street
Journal this air with Disney in
Hollywood there would have been a long
campaign to stop Disney building a
housing development up at the top of
Topanga Canyon and there are a lot of
people I think Susan lisman was
who really organized against it at the
ground but the crucial moment no that
was in the early times I was able to get
a column into the earlier time so I
think in environmental issues
corporations did not want to see
themselves pilloried you know in the
Wall Street Journal I mean I wrote
thousands of columns I mean not
thousands but hundreds about
intervention in Nicaragua by the regular
ministration you know which didn't have
any effect on anything really but the
idea was to get stuff on the agenda now
in 1990
Bartley said to me now that's the end of
that we're going to have a wider
diversity of opinion and have many
voices on the top right hand from the
left and the middle-of-the-road actually
didn't end up as al hunt little parking
preserve and he's I think he's got it to
this day hasn't he how come remember now
I mean other did I find the journal
pretty nuts these days I mean even nutty
and now than it used to be which is
saying quite a lot but this emailer says
the Wikipedia article on you indicates
that you've been critical of Noam
Chomsky if this is accurate over what
well I don't know I don't look at the
Wikipedia I'm no great fan of the
Wikipedia thing because all these things
come up and they're probably someone
who's got some little agenda and
Wikipedia put it in then you've got to I
suppose go and find another Wikipedian
to correct the record I think was some
some nonsense about my dad in there too
I had fantastic respect for Chomsky and
have you know written you know
strenuously when he's under vicious and
unmerited as sort of you know defended
him not that he really needs it for me
but you might think there are some we've
had some differences I think we do
differ a little bit on our estimate of
the weight of the Israel lobby in the
United States Noam Chomsky you know I
suppose is the position that you know
the dominant force the set of the agenda
the ruler of the roost is the United
States and it's a mistake to over credit
the lobby when it's really you know the
dominant forces and I'd I sometimes
think I differ a little bit on and I
have said I differ with Chomsky in
somewhat in that area but in general I
mean you know no I mean that's an area
of difference but I can't think of many
you're watching in depth our guest
Alexander Coburn we're going to go back
to the phone calls now Knoxville
Tennessee hello good morning thank you
for taking my call not them
seen you many times I watch you all the
time in fact and I've read thousands and
thousands of your words the hilarious
you had me rolling when you talked about
so mr. Rupert Murdoch but also about
journalism school I totally agree I
would like to say that of my own school
which I'm only partly affiliated with
now was brave enough to print columns
that I wrote I will say modestly and
they were about the whole 9/11
conspiracy they were I think very brave
in doing so and they allowed me to write
pretty much whatever I want that's UT
Knoxville's the daily vegan but I would
ask you to so really consider that this
really could have been a matter of
Intelligence Agency collusion and thank
you for writing those articles or having
those articles printed about the Mossad
information because that's all very
shaky incredible stuff that most people
haven't heard that also thank you for
we're talking about catalytic converters
like that group I think you're totally
right about this but I'll be brief and I
have two quick points but you should
also have people investigator write more
articles about building 7 which show
miss Rosie O'Donnell has been talking
about safety and have them also looking
to the many terrorism jewels that were
going on that day which machine could
function as a sort of supporter
confusion effort comment data confuse
all the air defense which is the main
mysteries 911 not buildings but the
failure of air Protocol that game Sanofi
no leave it at that
thank you very much well I think the
caller said some values I'm very happy
to be congratulated with my positions on
the catalytic converter of course but
here then he mentioned our coverage of
9/11 mm-hm and actually for a 9/11 or
personally I think attached is more
importance to the or more credence to
some of the allegations than I do very
polite to which I I thank him he asked
me about building 7 which was in third
building which went down I should say to
people if they want to read what I agree
with we have on our website on the right
hand side if you go down you'll see a
button which you can click on and
there's all the 9/11 stuff we've done
including a lot of stuff about about the
science of it by Manuel Garcia who is
about whose action
he works at Livermore who's done a lot
on the physics and he did I thought a
really good piece on building a seven
where the people who want to set an
inside job or it might have been
sabotaged
say well why did building seven suddenly
fall down and Manuel really goes I think
in support of the National Institute of
Standards and Technology report and on
the on the FEMA report in that instance
in pointing out you know that there were
these in vast tanks of diesel fuel in in
building seven which were going to power
the emergency generators the building
had been compromised struck by debris
from the first two buildings so that a
bit involved but what happened was when
the power went off in lower Manhattan
the emergency systems kicked in and
started pumping this diesel fuel
straight into a fire that had started
from the debris falling and this is I
think Manuel calculates it you know
really very thousands of tons of TNT
because it fed it pump diesel fuel into
a raging fire right next to the building
trusses this building seven was built
over a old Con Ed station and so there
were two three trusses that held it and
the fire was right next to now a
conspiracy lillte endlessly that the
fires you know couldn't burn out these
huge steel structural supports but they
can certainly compromise it so they'd
been and this fire finally caused it to
come down it's always quoted then that
they say the owner of building seven
said later you know let's pull it and
they say surely this is an admission of
deliberate sabotage which seems to be
ludicrous why would he admit this
publicly if he'd done it to the
insurance actually I think he was saying
you know he said let's pull the fire
crews out of it but it's all there in
manuals pieces and I thank you for a
very rational voice when you bring up
these issues Washington DC today how are
you I'm very critical of you mr. Coburn
the regicide diligently for five years
we first started and I think the base is
where I'm saying is it is liberalism
conservativism is this diversionary
argument we need the politics of realism
where what's being voted on the the
direct facts of what's being voted on is
this
that name-calling or swinging things and
if the politics of war and peace and the
diversion is going off you're talking
about
wait go that was a diversion for a
missile launch at Thompson number seven
April 7th you're talking about the
Bronco chase that's general Kagame
coming coming from Livermore Kansas an
army base there to invade in the eastern
Congo with five million people killed if
we talk about Iraq took about four
million people killed since Cheney said
this war is about oil in 1990 and
holding down a third of the oil
production world and keeping the cost up
that's the real effect in 40 years of
war Afghanistan there's a big new
Brzezinski laughs about how we - we
tricked them right into this if you talk
about Israel this is a version when
George Walker Bush his first day in
office shut down the peace liaison
office so for CIA between the
Palestinian sorry it was Railly
government work very well in Ireland and
96 Oz o cores is a set forward and this
is when Secretary of State Powell said
wait a minute
this is when he was put in the freezer
as his own words and told to be quiet
this is used as a diversion and if we
talk about color I'm gonna leave it at
that
diversion well I'm not quite a diversion
I mean the caller mentioned well I think
over maybe seven or eight episodes and
says they're all divergence I mean do
some of them that the things he
mentioned were significant episodes some
of them I didn't even understand about
something to do with Kagame and I don't
know I didn't quite get what the
connections were it seemed to me to say
that always that like Waco is a
diversion I don't think Waco is a
diversion
I mean Waco was something that just to
stay with Waco because he started with
that I don't wanted like I you said so
many caller that I couldn't quite keep
up with them frankly but I think what a
desire Shin now I think the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco I don't think people
said now we need a diversion to change
the subject from whatever infamous deed
were really up to and we need everybody
something to start thinking about you
know
waco the same way now I mean is the
thing that everyone in America is
thinking right now is did they buy the
wrong pet food last week and is this a
diversion from the Attorney General
scandal people are diverted from
thinking about the possible the rather
brief future of the Attorney General
General Gonzales but meanwhile they're
wondering whether they bought the wrong
kibble for the old hound now some people
say this is all a diversion from the
from something but you know it's it's
still a fact that you know apparently
all the dog food in the entire world is
made by one company in Ontario Canada
which is all very interesting and I hope
you know there might be hearings on dog
food coming up soon which people will be
watching like anything so to say that
things that diversions very often people
say that like you know Lewinsky gate was
a diversion
well it's something that happened at the
same time something else happened I
think people do try and do diversions I
mean to take an example which was really
serious when the Rwanda genocide was
going on the Clinton people said we
don't want to have diversion from people
concentrating on our onslaughts on what
was then Yugoslavia that was a people do
do diversions you know like they say
look at this so they won't look at this
but I think the caller and again it's a
little unfair of them because I you know
is a long list and I couldn't really
keep up with it it's a I deserve it all
divert since there are things that
happened and to see it always as a
pattern
I think people over see things as a are
carefully considered like you know you
suddenly say look at this pattern of
events it was all the Freemasons you
know that there's a strangely I think
the American imagination in every
imagination that establishes patterns
beyond what the evidence will permit
this book 1995 washington babylon
another great book which once told the
most by the way do you know oh down the
years I think probably corruptions of
empire which was the first collection I
did 1987 yeah that was a very popular
book then I think actually lighter 20
years ago I know every word still is
vital and peppy as it ever was
and then why
I think wizard is a consistent seller
still there are some books that didn't
sell so good I did a book on chess once
which I can see nestling down there yes
there's been there that I met up when
they out call her
earlier asked about oh yeah chess well I
did that when I was at the Village Voice
I had to do Village Voice books in fact
it was one of the reasons I was hired
but of course all and the idea was could
we get all the Village Voice writers
like the late Jack Newfield and those
people like that and then I would sign
him up but of course all these people
were signed up by mucky-muck publishers
already so I had to do one myself and it
was the Fischer Spassky match was going
on and I read a piece and I turned it
into an attack on chess I mean the
pretensions of chess that if you're a
good chess player you've got a mind like
Einstein a political instincts like you
know some the mayor of Boston in 1920 or
whatever it was and it's actually got a
very good class history of chess there's
a lot of rather bogus Freudian stuff in
there too but it didn't sell well
because the booksellers didn't know
whether to put it in the sports section
or the psychological section or the
political science section so I think it
was kind of a dud although got very good
reviews actually very good reviews back
to what Washington Washington Babylon
what were you trying to do with this
book
Washington Babylon was done to really
look at actually of course the title
takes off from Kenneth Angus book
Hollywood babble-on a book a great
gossip one of the greatest gossip books
ever written wonderful book and no
that's why we called it Washington
Babylon and it was also a little in the
tradition of there were kind of a series
of books called like Washington
confidential that people used to do in
the very old days in fact my dad was a
co-writer of one in the 30s he was here
for the London Times as a system
correspondent in in the late 20s here in
the United States and he was in New York
for the crash and he was in Washington
later and any and went to Chicago and
interviewed Capone and the like of it so
these were kind of an inside Washington
book and so we do the the media elites
we do the Pentagon we do this and that
the other thing in that book here's a
couple of what you said this is Charlie
Peters people and watch these band know
him and said the former headed now of
the Washington Monthly and you say that
the Washington Monthly has given
Armus pleasure to babylons elites with
the SAF s aides on neoliberalism iconic
iconic latin yeah well in the late 70s
on Washington Monthly in done indeed by
charge Charlie Peters was they had a
specialty of seemingly daring
challenging of received knowledge and
you know they had capable writers at
that game I think like I don't have Jim
fellows read to them at that point he
was one attorney yes yeah and there was
that whole generation all they were kind
of in a way Pro I don't know what you'd
call him but they they really were sort
of mainstream liberals who were
fearlessly challenging they seem to be
fearlessly challenging receive wisdom
but actually really what it was was a
cutting down of or final onslaught on
kind of the idea of left ideas that they
were near liberals in the sense that
they generally said you know efforts and
regulation of you know exercising
popular power that's what the logic of
it was were futile and full of hypocrisy
and pretension a lot of them were
attacks on you know the old Roosevelt
programs many of which were desperate
attempts to try and fend off something
to the left of FDR there's something
else you know everyone says you know FDR
the old left Democratic Party I mean a
lot of the New Deal which attempts to
head off something much more serious in
terms of you know popular upsurge you
know the Wagner Act came about because
people thought you know there were
millions and millions of people workers
you know and people who needed work who
are really going to overthrow the system
so you had to throw something and give
them a self of bread but meanwhile now
Roosevelt and the New Deal had been
positioned by the untiring efforts of
people like the late Arthur Schlesinger
and others as you know the sort of high
benchmark high-water mark of radical
possibility in this country absolutely
not true at all and so these Washington
Monthly writers you know many of whom
went on and sort of you know ended up in
the sort of the Democratic Leadership
Council or writing for the Atlantic or
whoever a part and parcel of this whole
onslaught on the idea of anything
particularly radical happening in the
United States here's a picture of lolly
Weymouth
The Washington Post and you wrote about
her should be blinding in accuracy of
her perceptions tantrums and incessant
rudeness oh I don't know let's pause on
that one
you're not going to take that on how
about Newt Gingrich you say about Newt
Gingrich he's one of the great welfare
cheats of all time yeah I think I think
oh yeah because I think what he when he
was in Georgia well he I think he was
constantly you know as usual with every
congressman you know Lord running for
his district I've forgotten what the
specific judges were mercifully you know
one-point Gingrich was up there you know
in in the in the in the Radical Pantheon
as one of the great menaces of all time
and I think it's are so lesson for the
progressive forces that very often look
at Republicans you know who come in like
English and they have an agenda which is
fine that's what you should have and
then they really push for it and then
they go on and on and on and finally
either they get nailed you know and go
down like Gingrich did or you know they
keep on slugging where it's very often
you know on the liberal end they have a
quarter of an agenda and by the time
they get into office have already
forgotten it we're taking a look at
another former speaker tom foley you
have in this book and you say that his
name will endure wherever grizzlies and
salmon died or where radioactivity
enhances nature's temple oh yeah well
that was a because tom foley was of
course from eastern washington and you
know if you're a politician from eastern
washington by and large they're not
totally actually hastened to say because
i have friends with politicians from
eastern washington and my admirer you
know you're going to intervene on part
of their let's say the Hanford Nuclear
Reservation up there that was the crack
about the nuclear power and you know yet
the politics of the Columbia River have
always been basically - you know until
you know with it there's some good books
on that but you know to make it
impossible for salmon to survive in any
you know possible form unless the poor
salmon entity try and climb up 200
ladders 83 dams get mashed up in boiling
nuclear waste and come out the other end
with some kind of mutant that's the
salmon for you and I think we said
Grizzly's hmm well again the politics of
the grizzly has exercised by Western
Standard or when Western congressmen are
not good for the grizzly the grizzly is
a beleaguered a beleaguered creature
anyone who does that can read uh
peacocks wonderful books on Grizzlies
you know there's an incredible fraud you
know that they're always exercising that
to do with Grizzlies and with wolves
which you've written about endlessly
well actually my co-editor Jeffrey
Sinclair is written wonderfully on this
issue when the Buffalo and what's
actually being done to exterminate these
these species let's get back to some
phone calls for you next is Los Angeles
policies been I haven't called number
thirty days and I'd like to not get cut
off and I'd like some fall looks like
the pro-israel collars head earlier here
thank you for having Alexander Coburn on
on the broadcast mr. Coburn I wanted to
address a couple issues from your
website and also in various books that
are out that just aren't getting
addressed to the extent they should be
in the pro-israel
press and media here in the States first
of all you had an excellent writer
Stephen green would written the serving
two frags piece for counterpunch you'd
written some earlier books as well about
the pro-israel lobby and individuals
associated with it like Richard Perle
who's part of be associated with his
Jewish Institute for national security
affairs
jinda and if you recall Washington Post
editor caring the young nubile book
about : powell you can look up jim's ax
in the index of it and it conveys that
the ginger crowd at least colin powell
has conveyed this recently i might add
for that book that the djinns and crowd
is in control of the pentagon so here we
have Steven green was actually brought
in as a consultant for the AIPAC case if
he reads the back of the paperback
version of Jane Stanford at pretext for
war book which conveys that we went to
war for Israel in Iraq and that we're
attacked on 9/11 tragically because of
us support for what Israel does to
brutally oppress the Palestinian people
mr. green was brought in as a consultant
on this AIPAC case and we don't see
anything in the US media about it it's
incredible
you can also what I have the call for
President Carter an earlier broadcast in
depth here miss Buble had said that Paul
Findley esteemed Republican congressman
had written various books on the
pro-israel lobby including they dare to
speak out has been on c-span's book TV
typically in depth could mr. Blake could
you cite the situation when he was
actually on your program and if you
can't and I'm pretty sure that you can't
why hasn't he been his they dare to
speak out book he conveys the power and
influence of the pro-israel lobby on the
Washington establishment Oh Thank You
caller well he mentioned Stephen green
well Stephen green is a very good writer
up in Vermont I think he lives and he'd
done some strong pieces which you're I
mean a lot of journalism's been done on
this now but I think he was a pioneer on
it you know tracing when looking at the
political backgrounds and loyalties of a
lot of people who did come into the
Pentagon and to the government with Bush
and Cheney you know and this it's been
written up a fair amount now you know
the the agenda for a new American
Century it turned out the people who
would participate in writing that had
been done an earlier plan which had been
written for Netanyahu in Israel which
laid out kind of the roadmap which for
an attack on Iraq and people have you
know written a fair amount about this
and also about the background of people
who ended up in the government in the
Pentagon like faith in the Pentagon and
so on
tracing tracing you know I think
convincingly so very convincingly so
there's no paranoia involved in this
just imagine looking at the names and
who they'd worked for and the various
you know Washington as you know is you
know pockmarked with all these various
you know quasi you know in all these
institutions you know like you know
whether it's Brookings or you know the
all these end that you know that the
political culture of Washington a lot of
policy is generated in these in these
think tanks which are you know
essentially political lobbying
organization and of course the Israel
oriented outfit so thick on the ground
and so this work goes through these and
says we're lucky you can just follow the
follow the trail so to speak of where
these people were what their political
sympathies are and what it ended up and
of course it ended up with these with
very powerful lobby with which pearls
name has been associated you know pearl
I feel like a thread that runs through
you know all the most disastrous aspects
of American political history as far
back as scoop Jackson in the seventy you
know as you know a terrible fellow but
but that's what I think that's what the
caller is talking about caller and your
question about mr. Finley yes he has
been on both TV Chicago go ahead hi uh
that's the first time I've ever gotten
sees them Bob I
I had a remark but my first comment is
on the people who call up and imply
anti-semitism because by calling you a
Holocaust denial that's the new buzzword
because anti-semitism is sort of giving
a bad name and if you know the humane
humane anti-semitism is kind of played
out as an insult isn't what you're
saying right yes exactly yeah so now by
painting you with the same brushes at
dingbat from Iran Holocaust denier
that's the new buzzword it's going well
I have I say on the record and I'm not
enjoying until this program I don't
think I was even associated with
Holocaust deniers I don't want to give
the impression that people watching that
you're looking at someone who's
constantly being I don't think anyone
actually has ever under course they
could not unless they were just making a
fantasy out of whole cloth to ever say
anything other than I've written you
know many articles which met absolutely
obvious I think that the Holocaust was
an absolute total and terrible reality
in human history I better make that
quite clear
thanks sorry go on Chicago what these
callers overlooked is that any you know
anytime someone like Noam Chomsky so I'm
on the talk show quarter century ago
offering some criticism of Israel's
behavior and of course a caller called
up and said aren't you one of those
self-hating Jews he's never call that to
a Jew in Israel in Israel I read Gideon
Levy I read her arrest
I read Arutz Sheva I read URI Avenue II
in fact I've met and spoken with them
they don't call himself hating Jews
that's ridiculous they call them lefties
pinkos Palestinian lovers but they never
call them a self-hating Jew however I
would like to give you a quick cake when
the spectacle of the withdrawal or
expulsion as they call it
settlers from Gaza was going on Sharon
was being challenged and announced by
everybody Under the Sun as having
betrayed and ignominious betrayal the
Jewish people and all the rest of the
hadn't I was moved to write a response
as Ariel Sharon might have written it
which would have gone something like
this listen dummies do you think I'd
betray my history my legacy I just took
a page from the American history book
which they can't criticize I'm going to
turn Gaza into a latter-day Indian
Reservation overcrowded borders
controlled by us coast control players
airspace controlled by us and that'll be
it
well that seems a fair assessment I mean
the fact of the matter is that I mean
Sharon you know one of them I mean like
a terrible malign thread in history way
back into one here to the days of what
battalion battalion 101 when he was you
know participating and organizing and
leading massacres of Palestinian
villagers back in the back in the very
early day in the early fifties and so on
and the idea that he had any benign
intent I mean I think the Gaza I mean
there's there any worse there are
terrible situations in the world today
but Gaza is certainly one of them and
literally you know they had the
situation there is indescribably awful
and I think in a way a lot of the Gaza
stuff was a sort of smoke screen to get
conversation while the wall was being
driven seizing a lot more Palestinian
land being driven across the you know
through orchards through houses which
are being destroyed and when people talk
about what would a second binational two
states look like what would a palace it
wouldn't be a state it would be tiny
little Bantu stars little enclaves you
know with the you know army only order
only well
is going through past them where you
know the village is cut off from their
fields you know the sheer quality of
life for a for a Palestinian farmer you
know five road blocks a day waiting two
hours your crop shriveling up in the Sun
that's what really is the future
therefore when you look at that and you
talk about a two nations solution I mean
people I really reflect like I've
married supported but I find it very
hard to attach much credibility to it
Haverhill Massachusetts yes thanks
Connie Alexander
nothing that epitomizes the ecology
relationships between the washington
press corps and the politicians in
washington the annual Correspondents
Dinner they give the other night they
had one and everybody gets together in
hahaha they all laugh at each other's
jokes and and they show Carl well the
other day on the dance floor bouncing
and jumping around with dick with David
Gregory and it IV car lighting was two
years ago at one of these dinners that
mr. Bush said Oh
with the weapons of mass destruction oh
the not only here or the not here either
or maybe them under here and everybody
was hahahahaha you know big big joke
well guys were getting killed and the
Iraqis naturally are suffering every day
getting killed so I mean these are two
groups that you know they your kids go
to school together they go up socialize
together they go to the same restaurants
and and it really hasn't been until the
war started going real bad that the
washington press corps has finally
challenged him on many issues so what
they had to but could you also comment
on jhinezka Senators campaign I'd
appreciate it thank you well the first
bit of the questions seem to be what the
cozy relations between the press corps
here and the government well I mean
that's been true down the decades I mean
you know you can if you go back to oh
the you know the Kennedy era you know
you had people like you know Joe Allsop
you know and you know basically you know
first of all in the one hand incredibly
close to the CIA to put it politely
secondly you know very very in camp with
with Kennedy you
you've always had because leading
journalists or opinion formers have a
very very often a strategic role to all
important tactical roles playing the
calculations of the powerful they're
going to be taken up and it's very
seductive when someone like Hughes idea
of Time magazine you know who I think
was responsible for the fiction about
the leg by JFK reading out of thousand
words a minute
he just says they know they pee and JFK
kind of made it up which you know I
remember being you know thought how
could he possibly do it his eyes must be
like a blur you know that people have
always been close there have been hold
out against the lure of the phone call
from the White House or you know the
quiet off-the-record conversation of
famous woman of course was easy stone I
have stoned you know who was genuinely
was an outsider or I think you know what
Drew Pearson you know who where Jack
Anderson started you know was certainly
taken very but in many ways was an
outsider and although we I mean it of
course he was part of the Georgetown sat
in many ways and but you know had a real
tough hard role to play so it's nothing
new on the other hand I think there is
definitely now there is a kind of
collective elite it was an amusing piece
the other day I've gotten where I read
it about the number of journalists you
know you know people at the front rank
so to speak who had their spouses or
their partners were like major players
in the political like working firm
McCain I think a couple of working for
McCain and the journalist was of course
the press person and therefore I think
in the case of buck it was Tom
rosensteil was it a Los Angeles Times
you know they took him off writing
opinion being a reporter because they
said his he might be the making in Pro
McCain stuff I guess the thesis was into
his pieces I would have thought they
editors you know if there were half ways
on their toes if they saw some huge plug
from the king yeah which I doubt
Rosenfield would try and do you know
they just take it out telling it's kind
of a little bit of posturing frankly but
there is definitely and it was in
Washington babble on the line yes yeah
we have a lot of that stuff where you
know Andrea Mitchell and and Greenspan
and Howard Fineman is actually one day
yeah that you are so yeah I think we
were helping Fineman and we said you
know there they are I think one of the
things is that a journalist you know
when I when I first came to this country
I was amazed I went on the campaign
trail was and I was amazed to see that
they weren't drunk all the time in
England you see the journalist a drunk a
lot I mean you and a fig Street is
notorious and correctly so I haven't
been there I mean I put four boozers you
know I mean you're talking people like
you know with little green things
crawling up their leg in the hospital
better with the DTS and I used and then
I got here and I thought I went on at I
said some at the end of the day you know
name until it will be wiped hardening
there in America we were in a motel on
the campaign trail and you hear all the
solemn voices of the radio people this
is Joe snow grocer you know they were
all still sober at seven o'clock and I
eventually decided the assault esteem of
a journalist in England was like very
low as Oberyn Wars said you know lower
than Bajor gases I mean you can't be
lower than a badger guy a guy who got
his badges but journalists had a low
sense of esteem because they were doing
things that were so odious morally
odious like including getting a bit
vague lling their way into people's
houses and getting photographs because
there was some scandal or you know in
the Murdoch press actually putting
secret cameras behind walls and spying
on people like they did with Tony
Lampton and so on and so forth low stuff
very low and so naturally in your moral
self torment you took refuge in the
bottle and here the self esteem of
journalist is a lot harder they
genuinely felt and start feels fulfilled
they have an important role to play
you know the fearless Patrol people for
the First Amendment in our
constitutional freedoms and so they now
but in those days earlier on I think
journalist Ben Bradley pointed this out
one time that you know it's easier to be
when you'll be paying very low money as
journalists pay twenty thirty years ago
is a lot lower but when you're a major
journalistic player you're in Washington
and between you and your missus or you
and your mister you're earning two three
hundred four hundred thousand dollars a
year you've got a real stake in the
system
you've got a fancy house you've got to
keep it all going you know your pally
with all the power elite and you're not
going to rock the boat so the idea that
you're a boat rocker in any way goes out
the window so you get less people you
know who at real are in the established
journalistic mainstream who feel they
can afford to be or in a position to be
you know throwing rocks at the green
house that's more I'll Roma want to go
back to your dear family a little bit
you talked a lot about Patrick who's
your other brother Andrew who lives
right here in Washington DC you just did
this terrific book on Rumsfeld I believe
he was a guest on c-span he was actually
yes and this is the book in the end the
newest book from from Patrick is the
occupation how did all three of you end
up in journalism well I referred earlier
to father Claude yeah and you know we
all admired him terrifically and thought
he'd you know he he sort of put the best
cast on journalism he said it's a it's a
crusading activity you know you can try
and promote your ideals and put forward
your ideals in your journalism
journalism is a is a is an activists
occupation to put it like that and he
was a very good journalist and also
terrific teller so we naturally admired
him and you know none of us became oil
company executives I'm sorry but for
mother and this is the three of you at a
much much earlier age which one are you
what to have is that creep on the left
you're the oldest you know that's
Patrick there at the bottom and there's
Andrew off there on there on the right
are you politics alloting I wouldn't
want to speak for them I mean you know
who knows what trouble I'll get them all
into I mean I don't think any of them of
will be running for that same Republican
New York City go ahead
oh yes gasps good morning actually um I
was wondering in the 40s and 50s
communist Russia sent spies throughout
the world they created these camps are
emulating America and England has a
large Communist Party there well now or
then now I don't believe so
I mean don't don't you see people like
demonstrating and and everybody says
that the
communists are paying the demonstrators
in England the common common are in
England I don't know they become this
party in England Virtual Assistants are
really ashamed you do you think there
are communists in New York City I don't
know I mean you mean a genuine
communists who are met didn't they all
just give all their papers to the to
some library I thought they kind of
given up
I mean God's going to move somewhere
else but I don't think it's a really a
functioning CPUSA what I believe is that
communism used illegal aliens oh there's
an emailer could you comment on the
demonizing of Hugo Chavez and the
manipulation of his intentions in
nationalizing Venezuela how does this
negatively impact the public's view of
Chavez and how does it complicate us
South American relations
well Shabbos the elected I think was it
three times elected now democratically
elected the president of Venezuela has
for the first time in a very long time
being using two good unsocial effect the
wealth of his country because of course
it's a leading has a lot of oil and it
exports a lot of oil and the price of
oil is extremely high serve them as well
it's got a fair amount of money and and
Chavez has gone for significant efforts
at redistribution for years decades and
decades and decades the people who are
now complaining and be thing about
Chavez never said a bleat when you know
Venezuelans little a leap and it's their
foreign sponsors and friends you know
looted 99.99% of the money stole it and
took it away from from the people and so
here comes Shabbos and that's a
significant thing that we've moved on
that I think now you know they're on
various he's a populist leader and he's
now trying to exercise more popular
control and he's openly proclaimed he
knows friendship and admiration for
Fidel Castro and there were signs that
throughout the Latin American continent
there are countries that you know would
like to follow in his path the lesson
here is twofold one you know that many
any years you know Latin America
followed the neoliberal part and the
part of being you know following the
economic first of all in the Kennedy era
and before the ice era if you were a
reformer just a reformer let's say in
Guatemala other countries you know the
CIA conspired with the right-wing elites
in your country to get you thrown out
either killed or run out of the country
and this went on whether it was in in
Guatemala in the 50s or right through
the attempts to overthrow Castro in the
late 50s under both Eisenhower and
Kennedy and then you know endless
interventions and so forth and of course
the onslaught on IND in 1972 in Chile by
Nixon and Kissinger politically and
economically that whole model the model
was neoliberal you know that if you sell
off all your public resources the phone
company the oil well the gas company
even they made an effort at one point
the rainwater that actually drips into
your rain tank that was in Bolivia and
sell them off to foreign corporations
hook your currency to the dollar or will
be well what it wasn't well the whole
thing ran into the Sun I mean the end of
the 90s Argentina which was meant to be
the most obedient neoliberal partner
they what they know the dollar and their
own currency was hooked everything was
cooked everything was going to be
hunky-dory
the country went broke and the president
and the Minister of economics had to
flee across the border pursued by most
of the you know in spirit and by the
Argentinian people who said this was a
complete disaster so that model ran into
the sand and so what we see now is
country saying there must be another way
same way in the other end of the world
you know people are say there's a better
way than going into debt to the
multinational institutions like you know
the IMF and the big international
institutions which of course ultimately
controlled by you know constant European
and American banks you know there's a
better way to run our destinies and
that's what's happened in Latin America
Chavez of course is then you know victim
of life is then tried to have a coup in
2002 and it's encouraging that they
failed miserably the coudé it was a
disaster and Chavez survived that in
managed to shoot him and he came back
and he's prevailed against all
opposition but obviously they say here
you know this is the blood-stained
village of a tyrant and prospective
Terrans needs another Fidel Castro and
the rest of it what do you expect he's
actually after all donating cheap home
heating oil to poor communities in the
American northeast it's kind of
humiliating that you know you have poor
people who can't get cheap energy or
home heating oil locally so Citgo which
is the Venezuelan owned entity here is
making available low low cost oil in
certain neighborhoods it's kind of a
slap in the face for Uncle Sam
Boise Idaho you're next hello hello I
wanted to say good afternoon mr. Coburn
and I'm a longtime nation subscriber and
I look forward to your column every week
I may not always agree with your views
but they're always thoughtful and
insightful and I thank you for them and
there were two things I wanted to ask
you about today the first is what I
would call the dismemberment of civil
liberties in this country under this
administration and the fundamental
changes in the bureaucratic structure of
our government and exactly how dangerous
do you think this is the second would be
your views on impeachment of this
president and in particular maybe the
articles I read in the nation from
Elizabeth Holtzman concerning
impeachment and thank you very much well
thank you for your kind words in Idaho
there on the constitutional issues yeah
they've been some very very serious
things that have happened in the in the
in the in the Bush era though I should
say that a lot of stuff that went into
the Patriot Act the stuff that you know
the the Justice Department in Clinton
era you know had already on the desk the
Justice Department is always looking you
know to reduce to keep up the pressure
to try and reduce what they regard as
inconvenient constitutional protections
and so forth and of course it's really
come to a situation a very profound
crisis
in the bush-era you know on matters of
but it's be under pressure for a long
time you know if you look at the Bill of
Rights you know the right to a speedy
trial you have people who you know it
wasn't just beginning in the bush time
you know spent years years waiting for
trial you know we'll leave aside cruel
and unusual punishment and the death
penalty stuff the justice system is
under terrible stress and abuse and has
been for a long time the whole plea
bargaining system is complete outrage
you know where they throw the book at
you and they say you are going to get 35
years in prison less you plead it out at
a lower rate and then your lawyer
finally says don't going that you know
you if you go down if you go if you go
non-guilty
and you go down you know you could be
you could be away for quarter of a
century or the rest of your life so you
better take the eight years that they're
offering you and it's all you know the
prosecutors does but until I have none
sympathy for any of these prosecutors
that you're now making such a fuss about
I mean Gonzales seems to averse his
aides had not been accurate in his
statements to use his word directly but
the idea that I think the Democrats in a
way are glad to get a subject which has
nothing to do with Iraq so they're
concentrating on the Gonzales affair but
every administration has used you know
appoint US attorneys politically they
all do it Clinton people did it and so
forth but Idaho you're completely right
in saying now you've got the military
commissions act you've got you know the
gradually the Posse Comitatus Act to the
19th century for prohibiting the use of
Armed Forces in in law enforcement
domestically that's being pushed off the
board you've got you know the the
ability for the feds to call on National
Guard's in ways they couldn't before you
know right through starting with habeas
corpus you know it's a terrible terrible
affront to constitutional Liberty and
you'll find as many people on the
so-called right in the you know in the
libertarian camp or in the
constitutional camp pointing this out
and sometimes more so I might say then
on the left that's point one now point
two I've talked so long about point one
I can't even remember point was that
impeachment well we have a lot of
writers on our website who go on
impeachment starting with our good
friend Dave Lindell who has written a
book about it
I mean I I have to confess I mean I
think there would be grounds for
impeachment
I personally dignity of every president
should face impeachment probably halfway
through their first term and should be
an ongoing process so I'm not against
impeachment I think I tend to think and
I don't want to like you know put down
the pro-impeachment forces but I'm Dave
writes peace but every other week saying
you know the tide is turning we got
impeachment coming over the horizon I
don't think it's kind of on the board's
myself and people invest in a way too
much hoping it as the south you know
people are always looking for things to
unlock the system so when impeachment
comes by golly then we'll get rid of
them the fellow you know impeach bush
then impeach Cheney and unaware we go I
mean I do say I think there are grounds
for impeachment but and of course the
ultimate parody was Bill Clinton being
impeached for the Lewinsky thing which
kind of brought impeachment disrepute
which was very sad because impeachment
so you know a sound principle I think so
I'm not quite as high on the impeachment
route as some including you and Idaho
I'm sorry to say email given the
overwhelming recent evidence like Gerald
Posner's book case closed
do you now believe that Lee Harvey
Oswald acted alone in the Kennedy
assassination well I tend I can say I
have said in the past more than once I I
tend to believe the Warren Commission
and people then raise their people who
don't raise a herculean Gustav laughter
and slap their legs to say what an idiot
and I think actually that the subsequent
in carries out including of the famous
Magic Bullet do ratify that position I
did Lee Harvey Oswald have any
accompanies a lot of people say now no
but if you were there
on November 20 afternoon of November the
22nd and you had Lee Harvey Oswald's
name in your rolodex how long before you
took that name out of your relatives and
tore it up
and burnt the remains and put them in
the trash I tend to think and I've
always thought that Lee Harvey Oswald
thought that by killing Jack Kennedy he
would take the pressure off Castro you
know and he saw that he saw the attempts
to kill Castro or something had provoked
him to do it there are a lot of very
peculiar things about Lee Harvey
it's true but by and large I do I tend
to agree that I tend doesn't to think he
shot him I think he did I think that the
way that the Warren Commission describes
it is correct so and I don't I don't
particularly agree with Posner this
emailer heard your discussion of
journalism schools earlier and asked you
for an aspiring journalist who doesn't
want to follow corporate media
guidelines how does one balance doing
good work and supporting oneself uh-huh
the need to make a living it's a tough
one I mean I think that I mean Geoffrey
Lance journalism when you're starting up
is a matter of scraping around trying to
find a little niche that you can go in
and you know part timing it or whatever
or going abroad finding some way to
maintain yourself while getting a little
clips file going or you know or trying
to do an article I my advice would be to
people starting don't spend too long on
a project very often you'll have someone
to get into a project and they spend
months if not years on it and you know
that it's not going to pay the mortgage
or the rent and you know you want to do
try and get things and also be general
don't get you can have an area where
you're saying to an editor I really know
about this
you know it's an area of speciality but
you know you should try and be but I
hope I could write about sixties causes
or you know or the Constitution or a
whole number of areas I used to write
for house and garden you know I reviewed
one of sharez houses I read lots of
houses I used to really enjoy doing it
because I liked architecture you I
reviewed movies I like to write about
food I like to write about everything I
mean you know who if on web on
counter-puncher we want to get a real
debate going you know 9/11 could move
over and get into barbecue we've had
some of our most spirited Rao's because
everyone in the country has it really
passionately held view about barbecue
and the Texans all come storming in and
say the best barbecue in America is to
be had in Lockhart that we got a piece
by jo-ann reproduce key on our website
about it all the best you know is the
stuff that's made in the Tidewater area
in North Carolina now that is an area
that it really interests people so
to get back to general you can be a net
how do we get into public you like
remember I think being interested in a
lot of different writing about gardening
I think you should be interested in
everything I mean I think radicalism and
I listening to the questions you know it
suddenly thought oh dear oh dear are we
going to get narrowed down to we're only
talking about Israel and 9/11 you know
whereas radical progressive journalism
covers hundreds of areas you know that I
believe you can have a cheerful
interested view of life Jeffrey and I
try and feel when we're not like Metro
lefties we live both live on the the
west side of the United States
you know Hylian are again and me in
Northern California that you know what
you do on in the nation what I when I
first began running for the nation
Victor Navasky was mad at me because I
wrote a piece once from Key West where I
was living at the time about raising the
Atocha which was the buried treasure
from the Spanish galleon that sank in
their 16th century and he thought I
should just do nothing but press
criticism and always be writing you know
meanwhile the New York Times in another
all that stuff I mean it's boring after
a while I think you know you want to try
and vary the mix in journalism and in
what you do and you babble want to have
a sense of humor it's thought sometimes
could be an offense against the laws of
man and God to make a joke I like to
make jokes I think a lot of life is
funny and so you can be I have a radical
outlook and still think things are
pretty funny and sometimes if you make a
joke people think this isn't you know
they say okay if you're an article you
make a jig have little signs say we're
now approaching joke population 550
words now you're not leaving joke you
know your signal it or you have to write
a Saeta we've given up on SATA because
when people write satires now you know
people believe it one of the things the
net produces is tremendous belief in
what people are reading so if you make a
joke people send us funny satires we've
kind of given up printing them because
next thing you know someone wrote of
SATA Ron Ron Jacobs one of our more
valued contributors whatever we
contribute is valued but you know a
valued contributor wrote a satire
involving the I think the arrests are
come into the circumstances now
something that happened in Iraq
involving an
can service person it was a joke the
next thing you know is you know
everybody it's gone round the net
everybody is saying it's true and you
then have to issue a retraction or
people say according to the joke website
counterpunch we don't want to be that
because what we write is stuff that's
true so wrote you wrote a column one
time it was about I think illegal drug
use and as you began it you said made a
big clarification to all law enforcement
everything from here on out it's a joke
it's a joke
you know I once waited years ago a
parody I addressed law enforcement I
don't know anyway I'm sure I did I read
a parody in the Village Voice years ago
as a conspiracy and it was a satire on
people like Claire sterling and honored
of butch Grove and Robert Moss these
were people in the late 70s in the warm
up to the Reagan era who were inventing
these enormous number of conspiracy
theories terror theories the terror
international the plot to kill the Pope
all of which was an attempt to demonize
and present you know the forces of the
left the Soviet Union is a power which
instead of being a power Andrew my
brother wrote a very prescient book
called the threat in the middle 70s I
think the only accurate work about what
the nature of the Soviet Union was and
which he just examined their armed
forces interviewed all the Russians
who'd come here realize that the armed
forces were in the state at the Serbian
areas in the state of decomposition I
mean it was worth more than a mile high
pile of CIA reports he actually got it
all right
but these people like moss and Sterling
and honor the Bush grave were being
briefed actually among other people by
the president Secretary of Defense gates
who then worked for the CIA or he was in
the National Security Council in
spinning all these insane fantasies and
I wrote a parody of it in the in the
Village Voice you know and it was
decorated as a parody we are little
black bats typographically you know
lying all over the page which were kind
of saying joke I woke up in the morning
that the voices to come out I think on a
Wednesday defined it being read I'd have
a WBAI
as a totally serious scenario so I'm
real I mean
Jonathan Swift wrote Gulliver's Travels
today it would be all over the net you
know that there were people you know the
Lilliputians and and you know everything
would be regarded as you know [ __ ]
people tying down giant cetera people
believe everything San Francisco go
ahead
hello mr. Coburn good to talk with you
thank you for coming on this show I
wanted to bring up your article that you
had written called the 9/11 conspiracy
nut and you know you're probably going
to get a call from one of us so you're
probably ready but I wouldn't consider
myself a conspiracy nut because I
actually try to stick with the facts so
what I'm going to do is present you with
a couple facts and see how you react to
him the first fact has to do with the
president's reaction on 9/11 and that he
actually is on record as saying that he
watched the plane hit the towers of the
tower I should say and that he then was
swept out of the room and brought to the
classroom I was wondering if you were
aware of the fact that and this is just
a state work what my sources it's from
the White House government news it's
from the White House website and on the
website President Bush is quote he's
responding to a question this was on I'd
Lisa in December 2001 he went to a town
hall meeting and here's his answer I was
sitting outside the classroom waiting to
go in and I saw a plane hit the tower
the TV was obviously on and I used to
fly myself and I said well there's one
terrible pilot I said it must have been
a horrible accident but I was whisked
out of there I didn't have much time to
think about it and I was sitting in the
classroom and Andy card my chief of
staff who is sitting over here walked in
and said a second plane has hit the
tower America is under attack now I'm
just curious whether you were aware that
the president
had gone ahead later and admitted that
he saw the second plane hit the tower
which to me is significant because that
would mean the whole little theatrical
proof performance there of Andrew card
coming out and whispering in his ear
America is under attack and I'm just
great does that seem like a newsworthy
item to you or you know it's like a lot
of the 9/11 I said I called you nuts and
I apologize every nut I mean non nut in
America I now call you conspiracists who
always very mad at me for calling you
nuts and you wrote me a thousand letters
all of them more or less identical
expressing your anger and outrage in
various terms and of course calling me
various rude names now that little
scenario about Bush I don't quite see
what it all adds up to really I always
thought he was slightly to his credit
actually the president that you know he
didn't want to upset these kids in the
classroom this is always presented as
either the fact that he's meant to be a
[ __ ] or you know delayed moral
reactions or whatever my fundamental
premise about 9/11 and you asked me a
little question there I know there are
nine thousand little questions that each
person who believes in the 9/11
conspiracy insiders job stuff believes
in I I just don't I think the evidence
as we marshaled it through Manuel Garcia
and points discredits the theory but I
don't want to get into that because we'd
spend the rest of c-span's time and plus
a thousand times more like rattling to
and fro over the points of all these
various arguments my fundamental view is
that 9/11 people tend to believe in the
perfect plan but now you seem to be
implying already there was a perfect bit
of theater laid out carefully for
purposes that I can't quite fathom in
the same way that everything else works
absolutely perfectly with clockwork
precision first of all is it likely the
dick cheney and george bush sat down one
day and said we want to organize a
pretext for a war on terror great idea
let's have these people fly into the
towers the subsets of this that they
were done by remote control there are
sub subsets it wasn't a plane that hit
the Pentagon although many people saw
the plane it was a rocket because
there's one whole one picture which
shows a whole
I can guarantee every conspiracy in the
country is now kicking the television
screen as I speak but it seems to me
that the idea first of all they would do
this mad cause if they were discovered
what they be stood up against the woman
shot after a rather rapid impeachment
and the Republican Party would cease to
exist if the conspiracy when you add up
the number of people involved is meant
to involve what 10,000 people 15,000
people none of whom have been on their
deathbed and said I have something on my
mind I'd like to say that I was part of
the 9/11 conspiracy and I planted a
demolition charge on the 85th floor of
the World Trade Center none of that has
ever happened
you're meant to presuppose at the
military now Griffin is the high priest
of all this nonsense says you know David
David Ray Griffin he's always built as a
theologian as though that's any
particular credential for talking about
you know 9/11 he says you know that
between the time the plane disappeared
from the FAA radar to the time that had
hit the tower which was in what 844 I
think 8:11 to 844 806 I can't remember
in that time everything should have
worked unless there was a plot by
clockwork precision that suddenly the
FAA would have immediately got on to
NORAD Nora would have got on to the base
commander the guy wouldn't be you know
in target trying to buy his wife dog
food or new kind of dog food they would
have rushed that got in the plane shut
up in the air located the flight 11
whichever one it was and shut it down
over Union City New Jersey I mean give
me a break any history of any event of
this nature shows you know multiple
foul-ups multiple multiple follow-ups
including the pilot the anything you
want me to shoot down that plane right
over the Hudson River you know where are
we talking about the whole probability
from the reason for doing it to the mode
of execution to the analysis of the data
to the reason for the collapse of the
building seems to me to nullify the
conspiracy theory I don't believe in it
I think the evidence is against it I
think some of the people who are pushing
out are indeed nutty other people are
well-meaning but I'm misled by evidence
other people at some point cannot listen
to any other point of view we published
all these endless scientific and
and when I offer them to people or when
when Manuel Garcia does or Jeffery does
I don't think they ever read it they are
already convinced there is a strain in
America that needs a plot needs like
three Mesa Grande Masons or it needs and
the other thing is rather racist they
say you know Arabs could have done it
you know they say you know can this have
been done by Arabs living in caves well
is that saying that the only people who
could do it
ah we might have done it to ourselves
but no one else is capable of doing it
that seems to me rather a racist
position United my bit you mentioned
earlier about the letters that come in
to you why in 1995 did you compile a lot
of letters into this book well it's not
just letters that's about that's
actually my favorite book the golden
ages on H yeah I think it's a it's a
really a journal about you know from
1987 to 1994 which was well of course it
was the downfall of the Soviet Union is
significant many significant moments in
world history economic and political
history was stylish the Dutch Journal
right it's a journal it's a journal in
which letters occur and I put the
letters in because a lot of my as I
guess people can see a lot of my you
know a lot of my life is a political
life and then select your life is fairly
contentious and I don't mind
contentiousness it doesn't bother me
people say I I got these terrible
letters I mean a letter over the
Internet does not hurt you I mean a
something you know other things can hurt
one physically but if you're robust I
hand it out to people I've got to be
prepared to be on the receiving end you
know of polemic I don't mind polemic at
all this book it's not a lot of that in
it I tried to show really the life of
someone of my outlook intellectually and
also geographically and to some extent
emotionally in that in that book why did
you include in it a letter from someone
saying they glad they were glad your
mother was dead Emma glad it was
actually as someone who didn't like my
criticisms
State of Israel and I put it in to show
these people it's like the guy who rings
up about the Holocaust they will scorn
no weapon
I mean I've looked at it I just thought
this guy I would like to show someone
who read a column of mine maybe notice
that I said my mother was dead and felt
impelled to get a piece of paper right
on it and actually signed it I think
he'd give his name but right I just it
was a one-line thing signed his name at
the end of it and went down to the stack
it is an emblem put it off and
presumably felt well I've shown that guy
what I think I'm glad I don't say I'm
not I wish you were dead which is a
reaction but I'm glad your mother is
dead in other words it was an expression
of I thought you know venom which is his
size truly pathetic
Madison Wisconsin hello hello the first
time I've ever heard of you and you're
an amazing intellect what a fabulous
although I consider myself from the
opposite end of the political scale I
find myself agreeing with nearly
everything you've said except maybe on
this which you alluded to slightly
referring to Al Gore's movie what's your
opinion on the use of nuclear power oh I
think the practical histories that well
thank you for your your nice words and
I'm glad that I can reach beyond the set
of speak people who might already know
my writings although I have many friends
in Wisconsin I don't know where you are
in Wisconsin but I'm glad that you find
that things I say of interest and might
even agree with some of them on nuclear
power I just think we know the the way
that nuclear power the the grid
organization the safety issues the
social energy organization that is
required to produce nuclear power is is
is establishes a series of penalties and
and situations which I think we
shouldn't have you know I mean just look
at nuclear the generation of nuclear
power and power as it's occurred in the
Pacific Northwest or you know power
plants or whatever it is like that's the
reservation connected with the
manufacture of uranium and so forth it's
look at Chernobyl look at all these
sites that it's not worth the candle
there are other ways you should go
that's my basic position on nuclear
power couple other issues then monitor
just jump in on illegal immigration well
you can argue that I mean my feeling on
the illegal immigration is you know that
it is fundamentally wrong for a country
such as the United States to have a lot
of its economy posited on labor
demanding labor which they then cause to
be illegal
the California agriculture would
collapse without illegal immigrant labor
illegal in the in the words of the state
or you know as they found in Northern
California last year when enforcement in
Lake County for example up northern
California and a lot of laborers
wouldn't go up there because they feared
arrest and deportation and so the crops
all lay on the ground and so why I have
a situation where you say our economy
depends not just AG agriculture but you
know construction in whole areas you
know we're talking about southern Kansas
before the show began you know you can
drive through southern Kansas now and
you can listen to you know Spanish radio
because there wasn't 220 years ago the
economy requires labor so now you have
people who have to come up meanwhile you
then espouse economic policies south of
the border like you know with neoliberal
reform in quotes that destroy let's say
Mexican agriculture because now you
drench the country under pre so-called
free trade free to dump you know a
Canadian an American corn in Mexico and
wipe out the the small peasant who can't
exist or earlier on you deny land reform
in Honduras and in Guatemala
you know when they tried to do it in the
50s so gradually you make it impossible
in these southern countries for
peasantry to survive and make a go of it
you know you suppress land reform and we
support the landlords you support the
the powers that be
you support the army you wipeout on it
and what do you get you get a tidal wave
of people from Donna's father who come
up north because it's the only way they
can go you've destroyed on you and the
clients whom you're sponsoring and
helping down there you've destroyed
their conditions of life they come north
they go to the cities and then they go
north to work meanwhile you've
established an economy here that
requires the labor so now you then rear
up and you make your fence across the
border higher and higher and higher so
the people who might have seasonally
come across the border and gone back now
if they get across their Shores have not
going to try not to get back because
they can't get back so you've created
the conditions which require it and then
you penalize it so how can anyone then
stand there and say I call these people
illegal as of course the people who are
rendered illegal by system but once
their cake and wants to eat it that's
what it comes down to one more issue gay
marriage well I don't know I've come out
against it you know partly got my good
friend Bill Dobbs point him in this
direction because why would an
institution which is basically taking
Church principles you know and applying
them to a state license for people to
get married be regarded as progressive
I mean why suddenly after years of
talking about the oppressions of
marriage should you I mean if gay people
want to get married that's their good
thing but to regard it is kind of a
radical demand doesn't seem to me very
radical at all you're saying I would
like the credentials of the state which
in many ways our regard is oppressive
and intrusive on you know human freedoms
and you want to allow the the licensing
capacity of the state with the licensing
capacity of a religion and then you
that's marriage right and then you call
that let's have a final means let's have
a civil ceremony but let's get the
church out of it so what to call this
radical progress doesn't seem to me the
case at all and I think many actually
gay people rather agree with that
position
madisyn main go ahead yeah hi I'm a
longtime admirer I'd like to hear your
comments on the following if not one boy
bullet or bomb had been sent to Vietnam
considering the geopolitical menu with
China and Russia at the time why do you
think would have been the result in that
you and second any comments further you
have about trial treatment I'd like to
hear and third your home in California
looks great great place to live well
it's true the latter question petroleum
it's a what if question about Vietnam
you mean if if if the the famous
election that elected Ho Chi Minh let's
say in what 1954 if the US hadn't
already been intervening to try and say
French colonialism after diem bien phu
if the if the eisenhower administration
said okay let let let you know vietnam
be united under the leadership of Ho Chi
Minh well it's a what-if question and
what if questions are by definition what
air and sometimes they're fruitless to
explore but certainly the premises for
saying if we let that happen
you know the domino theory well sent
will lead to a fantastic triumph for
communism all of these theories all
turned out to be completely wrong so of
course I would say I wish that that had
happened because you know how many
people died in the Vietnam War I mean
aside from US casualties what is it I
mean I submit the normal rating is 2
million McNamara in his his interviews
what a couple of years ago now said
three million you know I mean you know
staggering staggering toll so it would
have been better the second question was
you I saw you Tom Frieden Oh Tom
Friedman I mean give me a break he's
wrong about absolutely everything I
don't know if semester it shows the I
mean I'll just say a word about the
punitive the utter corruption I don't
believe really in journalistic prizes
the I better be careful because I think
my brother Patrick and here were very
replace had got a rather good prize that
the other day and was up for another one
so I watch my words here but the Martha
Gellhorn prize he got Neyland Lomond was
once edited by a guy called Hugh their
birth marry a very good editor of the
French newspaper LeMond many years ago
and if I were if I journalist on his
Lamond accepted a prize they got the
boot they got fired
the prizes there's an issue of editor
and publisher item they still put it out
which is as thick as the phone directory
with prizes the journalist can put
inputs like an industry newspapers used
to have or may still have departments
whether you know it all the time they're
preparing for a whirl and the times and
these people are grubbing for prizes all
the time earlier dominate there's
something specific about Tom Friedman
though I mean well I think he irritates
a lot of people in the left because he's
sort of at a sort of a high voltage
level of pomposity and [ __ ] ISM I mean
that his books are all nonsense here's
his benefits been on the New York Times
bestseller list for almost two years
which shows though a lot of people are
prepared to buy nonsense I mean you know
they buy they buy dog food and they buy
nonsense I mean you could prepare dog
food better and you don't have to read
nonsense
I mean Freedman really is wrong about
things he's wrong in his claims but
about neoliberalism he's wrong in saying
the world is flat he was wrong about the
war in Iraq he was wrong I mean and
brutishly wrong not just wrong brutishly
wrong so a lot of people not me I may
say spend a lot of time getting really
mad at Tom Friedman which I think
sponsored the question but it's kind of
silly I think it in like you know flow
Barre Road blue bar and peckish a you
know bye to two people endlessly of
spouting nonsense and you know you could
take Friedman on the one hand and any
one of the other sort of blather is in
the mainstream pundits that occur so
that's the Friedman thing but an email
come that came in from a
sixteen-year-old and I want to read it a
little bit longer but want to read it to
you says this I'm 16 years old I live in
Florida I would really be honored if you
would answer a few of my questions and
allow me to tell you as a young American
how this has affected me I hate politics
and politicians
I believe that Machiavelli was basically
right I have no faith in the goodness of
humanity I was born a cynic and I grow
more cynical daily for six years I've
had to watch these men Evelyn's morons
the Bush administration lie lie lie
commit crime after crime and laugh at
the Correspondents Dinner while hundreds
of people are blown up every day in Iraq
and Osama roams free to top it all off
they are completely incompetent have no
idea how to run a government and are
doing everything possible to destroy
this country
the only news I watch anymore are the
Daily Show and The Colbert Report I
would consider myself to be pretty far
left in my views I don't support the
Republicans because they are evil and
the Democrats because they are spineless
he goes he or she goes on what do you
say to that pretty well I say a lot of
it the person is there as an everyman
limbs Liz I think it I think she I'm
glad that Liz I think everything your
analysis of the conditions is great but
I don't think you should be a cynic I
think you should have ideals and beliefs
which I think you do and maybe you're
doing yourself injustice by saying
you're a cynic you might be cynical
about the pretensions of government over
the Republicans government as it exists
Republicans and the Democrats from where
you sit in Florida but that doesn't mean
you should be cynical because it could
be sinesses cynical really I think means
that you don't have a core of hope and
optimism and belief in yourself or I
believe you know in what might change
things and I think change comes from
being not believing the potentials of
power or the claims of power or their
claims they did this or they did that
well and will have good effects and
consequences but to come just to decry
and just to let's say watch Colbert or
the the comedy show or you know the
Stewart thing is limiting I think you
should constantly be people in the end
want to hear a vision that convinces
them you know whether it's in Florida or
Maine or the state of Washington or
Arizona or anywhere there's something
that they can relate to so I often say
the people on the left to have a kind of
ghetto mentality you don't if you like
forming a coalition with people in your
community that don't necessarily hold
all your beliefs but if you believe in
gay marriage they don't necessarily
believe in gay marriage or if you
believe in this will happen the other
thing but there are certain things you
can make common cause on right now most
of the country are against the war in
Iraq a majority they're really against
it you know and so and they're not just
on the Left they're across the board or
right now people feel that the
institution the Bill of Rights is under
pressure you can form common cause with
those for an idealistic vision they will
move you forward so I think at the age
of 66 46 as well as at were you were 16
it's wrong to say I'm cynical just
cynical you've got to have a stronger
core of positive belief than that
Berkeley California hi this really kind
of follows on what you've just answered
but it comes at it from a slightly
different perspective and you I think
having a British background not review
some real insight I listen to deal Conan
on PBS he does a good job and he was
talking to a commentator I think was
really kind of stupid in st. Louis I
assumed he was NPR PBS and the whole
thing was how do you see these firings
of the prosecutors and I want to tell
you how I look at it and then see if you
hone in on this and it's really the
educational system in this country and
how we look at it history and why it's
so fought people look at the prosecutors
and they say the president has a right
to nominate them and also they're at
will they can be terminated any time but
it's like putting a judge in you put a
judge in or prosecutor they have the
same power they shouldn't be pulled out
for political reasons and a Carole lamb
the woman in the prosecutor in San Diego
said I don't have time to do all these
little cases I'm going after political
corruption which in that case happened
to be Republicans and she was doing a
very good job of it which means if they
want her to go after these other cases
little cases in people coming across the
border
give her more money give her more budget
but I think they use that as an excuse
or could have used it if they done it
right to remover the average American
even somebody that's college educated
looks at this and say well they have a
right to remove them I don't think they
have a right to remove people when
they're doing their job correctly
that's tampering with the system and the
average American that they want to talk
about football and that's what this
commentator in st. Louis did he wanted
to talk about the Cardinals how stupid
to say that people are not interested in
this and st. Louis that they're that
stupid that you know they're going to
regress the talking of
football scores now let I've said the
question and set it up I think you can
articulate it better than I can
that's what I have well I'm the
prosecutor thing I think talk about it
for a minute before and it gives it also
I mean you're right it does go back to
what the caller from Florida was saying
it it's not cynicism but realism to look
at the justice system in the United
States and says it is top to bottom
political I mean I'm not saying there
are great judges I'm not saying there
are decent prosecutors although I mean
I've been good to find it can't how many
decent prosecutors there are prosecutors
there are way too many prosecutors who
go into politics you look at you start
cutting up how many prosecutors there
are in politics it's an awful lot how
many public defenders other in politics
not so many prosecutors in the system as
we now have it you know tend to you know
as I was saying earlier they administer
the justice system in a way that you
know demand they go up to someone they
they over they overcharge to get the
plea bargain so they can get this keep
on you know keep the system going
through judges you know might have got
in you know there are some again decent
honorable judges but you know judges got
in for political reasons you know their
careers have been advanced you know up
through the system whether it's the
federal system of the state system by
systems of political patronage we live
in a judicial system that is politically
conditions and inflected ultimately in
the protection of you know the
ultimately the protection of the rich
and the you know the oppression of the
poor is what it really comes down to and
to say it's not true that is to I think
by naive which is just as much as
sinners to be supposedly cynical that
doesn't mean them Islam or whatever
wasn't in that particular instance doing
okay but I would I find a little
hypocritical now is for all this
thundering I mean Gonzales I'm glad to
sees in trouble I don't like Gonzales
he's the man who you know says
Guantanamo is great I mean he's his in
his actions have been a hideous abuse of
constitutional systems and he should be
you know put out or impeached or
whatever it can be done on that basis it
seems according to his own assistance
that he's not been entirely forthright
or accurate in his remarks about himself
too
judge what the other fellow said just
yesterday or the day before but to say
for the Democrats to be standing right
up there and saying this is an absolute
outrage this is an impugning and
infringement on the normal is smooth and
party parties and free operations of the
US Justice Department and the
appointment of US Attorney
I mean give me a break really that's not
true so I mean I to say your questions
seem to be premise on a disinterested
judiciary at some level of theory which
is I think conflicted almost entirely in
practice this emailer wants to know if
you will be writing about the
unification Church as you have written
about the Church of Scientology what
have you written about Scientology oh
the Scientologists I'm always in trouble
about Scientologists because no I have
no plans right about the unification
Church by the way I don't think not that
I know of unless something comes up the
Scientologists it goes back to what I
was saying about cult you know this if
you use the cult would you know people
have put up and they say we know it's a
license to free fire now the
Scientologists you know come under a
heavy attack all the time years ago Time
magazine put them on the cover they put
them on as an octopus as though this
this this octopus was lying across
either the world or the United States
and odd that many Scientologists but it
was like a huge threat and oddly enough
the guy who wrote that I think labeled
me at the same time like so they I think
he mistook me from my brother I'm not
uncommon event and I sort of you know
got to know some of the people in the
Scientology Hiba jens's the head of the
International Church and you know we had
areas of common interest like you know
going up to Time magazine for example
and I felt and feel that I said to
people when they say there's a
Scientologist how can you possibly even
talk to them why having to do I think it
was more evil in one second of the
history of the Roman Catholic Church
then there is in the entire lifetime of
Scientology which only began in like
1954 and the Catholic Church has been
going since uno
several you know a couple of millennia
practically you know and let's not go
into all the things that the Catholic
Church has sponsored starting with the
crusade and so let's have a sense of
proportion I are you a saint ouch no no
no no no I'm not a Scientologist at all
I don't really know that the the whole
eschatology and performance of the
sounds I do know areas they've done
working like they've done a lot of work
on the CIA very creditable work stuff
that's been got by Freedom of
Information they've done very good work
on pharmaceutical companies very very
good research creditable researcher
stand up in the late 70s they did a lot
of work on secret army testing you know
chemical testing actually if you go back
and look up the clips at that time they
put forward their researchers are the
arm US Army chemical outfit and the CIA
had done these secret tests where they
were actually you know spreading poison
gas in subways there in I think Sebring
Florida they were they were testing
things all the time as they were in the
fifties and the sixties and to this day
probably in which millions of Americans
have been poisoned in one way or another
you know we've probably killed and
poisoned you know just by nuclear
testing Pro digis numbers of people
absolutely prodigious the casualty rate
from the Co boring human physical terms
in this country is absolutely immense
the Scientologists did good work
now I meant to say well the
Scientologists did that I'm not going to
read that stuff I have read it and I've
used it and it stood up it's very good
research I think demonization of the
unusual a lot of American political
culture is saying you can't think that
you can't go there you can't like these
people you can't even notice these
people you know it's meant to be like
when these candidates get going like
some poor fellow like Obama you know
then basically the first months of your
kind of state of systematic denial you
never said anything in favor of labor
you never said anything that might be
mildly critical no no no the State of
Israel you never did this you never did
that and gradually the elites are
satisfied that you might just be
respectable amount to run for high
office
I always remember years ago Senator
Harold's use of Iowa he was on CBS one
time years and years ago he was a very
good senator from Iowa I think he was a
former truck driver or something
and he said to him at one point senator
Hughes are you a candidate for the
nomination I've got news even a
Republican or a Democrat behind is
probably a Democrat
and he said when I tell you that I
believe nuclear war leads inevitably to
mutual obliteration and that therefore
if I was told as president that Russian
rockets were speeding towards the
continental United States I would not
order a response he said you can
understand from this that I'm not a
candidate for the President of the
United States I thought what a good
answer you know that he was prepared to
take the premises of the question like
the only way you can be that
particularly asked you to women are you
prepared to obliterate the planet
because if you aren't prepared to
obliterate the planet you have no right
to the president United States are you
ready at any time to press but may and
say wipe the whole thing out we've had
enough humanity can't last another ten
minutes if the candidate you know
particularly if it's like a woman says
oh actually I think it's a bad idea to
destroy the planet I'm rather against it
not up to the job completely insane
hello Jay Georgia
Connie love c-span great interview I
just want to ask mr. Cobra mr. Coburn I
am really fired up about Mitt Romney I
think he could be the greatest present
every my heroes Ronald Reagan my
question to you is how do you compare
Romney to Ronald Reagan and how do you
think mr. Romney will do them hope you
fail do well oh I don't know wave got
the idea my thing Ronnie will do well I
don't particularly care for Mitt Romney
and I have some very disappointing
chapters about Ronald Reagan me and end
times are fine new book in which we have
a chapter actually was one is but most
the book is written by me or Jeffery on
the Great Communicator
I don't think Reagan was a great
communicator I think his presidency was
a disaster for American I think I I've
never understood how people now solemnly
the sudden guy wrote an absolutely huge
book the other day saying you know this
was one of the finest political brains
and one of the greatest all tissues in
history United States Ronald Reagan I
have it absolutely I think I'm tangible
authority that when he got in he used to
get briefings from the Joint Chiefs of
Staff
and they would you know given the state
of play around the world and they
noticed that the president sim didn't
seem to like this very much in fact
dozed off as they were giving him the
state of play so they acted they drafted
in some cartoonists into a secret unit
to draw in cartoon form the state of
play so there would be the Russians with
enormous Zeppelin like ICBM missiles and
on the American side tiny pygmy like
missiles in fact Nixie porn it see
another horrible figure in American
particularly just to go arm it kind of
like it was like a croquet rack of these
missiles to show all and it was a
cartoon about the State Fair and Reagan
really liked it he'd like for he'd like
reruns and that was the way he
approached a lot of government like I
remember you'd listen to Reagan giving
political you say the Reagan you know
one given the recent history of Lebanon
and Reagan would plunge in with an
absolutely fictional account of the
history of Lebanon was enjoyable but had
no relationship to reality let me read
just a couple senses that you wrote in
this most recent book about actually it
wasn't about Reagan necessarily but
about people in the in the aftermath of
his death you wrote I have boundless
faith in the American people but it was
startling to see the lines of people
sweating under a hot Sun waiting to see
Reagan's casket how could any of them
take the dreadful old faker seriously it
was kind of what I felt I know there are
great admirers of Ronald Reagan started
with my neighbor Peter Hannaford but and
I'm sorry if I seem disrespectful to the
memory but I don't think I think he was
he elevated the national fantasy it was
a tremendous that there is an element of
fantasy in everything he did and it had
like you know I could do an example I
mean of what communicating really meant
well you know when the Christa McAuliffe
and the others went down in there in the
rocket why was why did they launch that
rocket out of Florida on a cold and
frosty morning when the o-ring was going
to crack many engineers said wrote you
know later I I remember I wrote a column
at the time it was in the nation
questioning saying you know why did they
have that hat
had NASA had to have that rocket taking
off in Canaveral because the Great
Communicator wanted to stand I was at
the speech the State of the Union
address or something and he would be
able to look up you know I'm pointing to
up there is I don't know the beacon of
freedom whatever it was and that
required them to have that coincidence
of time to have the rocket taking off in
Florida it's time when it was putting it
in what turned out to be a terminal
peril that was communicating at the
level of another communication you know
that they sent the bombers bombing Libya
so that they managed they were doing it
in time for the network news here of
course the bombs missed their target
which was an attempted assassination of
Gaddafi and that killed his his daughter
his stepdaughter
that was another everything was
contrived the way they described Reagan
the communicated conditions under which
he operated the phony speeches that he
said and it all elevated into fantasy
what was actually going on in the world
I'm sitting here looking because when
you said daughter and I wanted to show
our viewers a photo of your daughter
which I will continue to look for who is
your daughter Daisy Daisy Coburn she
lives in London well I'll tell you what
I'll keep looking for the picture was we
take a call let's go to a Greenville
North Carolina go ahead
hi I'm going low in the third year
medical students British born Nigerian
I've been in the u.s. from 12 years
I saw Dennis Kucinich at the National
Convention for American medical students
I think was a couple of months ago I was
very impressed with the fact that he was
a fresh voice he's idealistic but feels
very practical interested in providing
universal health care Department of
Peace I'm generally stream streamlining
the whole political situation from a
suitable companies insurance companies
oil companies and all that you please
talk about him I know a caller called
earlier but you didn't address it thank
you and oh this is Dennis Kucinich Oh
Dennis okay well I think Dennis Kucinich
has many views that are absolutely
excellent and I would kind of be more
excited about his candidacy except that
I think a lot of people as I said I
think earlier felt a little burned by
what he did in 2004 when he went on the
campaign trail with quite a lot of
support and you know was speaking in
favor of all the things that the caller
quite correctly I did
side kucinich with whether it be you
know money only for the troops only for
fighting in Iraq so long as it goes
towards bringing the troops home whether
it be for you know single-payer health
insurance for you know diminishing the
part of the militarism in the country
and all the rest of it
I mean his view is they're approachable
but does it end up with in if he I mean
his chances of success are slim to put
it as it's most optimistic does it end
up with what he did in 2004 which was to
go to the convention in Boston and then
stand you know raising John Kerry's hand
the hand of a man whose views he'd been
decrying and just basically now saying I
am a Democrat for first and foremost and
you know you don't you don't get me but
you get him a guy who stood in sharp
distinction to almost every belief that
Dennis Kucinich howls so that that's why
I think I have some reservations I'm
sure he said a very fine speech to you
in Greenville South Carolina where I
have very good friends who live quite
close to their to him found the photo of
Daisy oh you did how old is she
Daisy was born in 1969 and where did
where does she live now did she lives in
London and what are her politics well I
wouldn't presume to speak to the
politics I think she seems to quite
agree with things that I write although
because she's more in an English context
but I don't believe she'd she's a fierce
conservative put it like that what else
you want to tell us about well I I could
go in a great length to a wonderful
marriage so I will say that she is an
exponent of the Alexander Technique
which isn't a deferential nod to her dad
but is the Alexander Technique which is
the form of physical therapy which was
started by a guy called ft Alexander in
Australia at the turn of the 20th
century which which is a it's a form of
physical and spinal adjustment and as
her particular expertise so she
chiropractic it's not exactly
chiropractor where they it's sort of I
don't it doesn't involve as
chiropractors can do but fairly fierce
laying on of hands you can straighten
the spine and all the rest of it but
it's a much more subtle affair of
combating instinctive physical responses
that cause you know
pain or improper you know deployment of
your body next los angeles hi hi I'm
calling the mrs. Norris and I would like
to know why you don't have Paula Paul
Findley on your program and talk about
the book dare to speak up because
everybody in America is not daring to
speak out and and about the Israeli
Lobby and it's absolutely atrocious as
far as I'm concerned and took us through
Iraq and it's a mess and if we go to
Iran will it'll be the end of the world
as far as I'm concerned and I'm 78 years
old I was born in India and my father
was a racehorse trainer there and I
really think that the Americans have got
everything screwed up and I think you
should stop making everybody so unhappy
and mr. Coburn I'm very pleased to meet
you and I and I hope that questions I
know that good I knew the Christensen's
and I thought they were excellent and
they write in your paper thank you very
much for appearing because you need to
be on every day as far as I'm concerned
but for the Kristensen oh they're
referring to a valued counterpunch
contributors build
christeson and kathy christmas and the
christians both worked for the CIA in
fact bill christeson was a very very
senior national officer to the CIA and
advised President Ford at one point and
now they they live in Santa Fe overtired
and bill and both of them have done a
Kathy kisses in his particular area of
interest is Israel and Palestine bill
has done many tremendous pieces in fact
he did a piece right after 9/11 which
was really saying you know why did they
do it his views have evolved a little in
ways I don't totally degree with on that
11 specifically but um then he wrote I
think one of the best pieces are what
are the real causes of terror you know
right after 9/11 there was a brief
moment when people said we'll hold on
why did this happen what have we been
doing in the world there was a moment
that it seemed like it might be a moment
of self national self scrutiny and that
rapidly disappeared into you know the
war on
which excludes you know even
consideration of what might be provoking
terror and you can conditions be altered
so that terror would necessarily arise
you know what you think any reasonable
power would do oh and Bill wrote a long
piece saying well here are the various
reasons why they did this and it was a
very pioneering and important piece
which actually people can get it on our
website a couple people brought up Paul
Findley have you ever written anything
about him yeah I've been about finding
um he is I mean he was congressman of
course from what Illinois who think Sam
was put out and you know under pressure
because he was a supporting the
Palestinian lindley and the Israel lobby
I think you know just made it impossible
thing I mean he didn't survive
politically the same way Senator Chuck
Percy didn't and you know people like
Cynthia McKinney and Hilliard in Alabama
and Moran in Virginia he survived came
under pressure because they did dare to
speak out for Palestinians and if you do
that in the American political context
in the congressional context it's very
often being lethal for your political
careers I think the caller was wrong and
saying no one dares to speak out I think
people are increasingly talking pretty
frankly about the power of the lobby and
you know what it can do what's done to
the politics of this country that has
changed the future of counterpunch well
expanding and glorious I think I mean we
we attract more your readers and all the
time both the newsletter and the website
we have a very very large members
reading the website I think people like
the fact you know it's it is independent
we're not like a like move on you know
an extension of the Democratic Party
we're not like totally politically
obsessive
I mean Jeffrey's never happier than
writing about the Blues or writing about
the environment or floating on rivers
you did a wonderful series in the summer
you know we talked about barbecue we
talked about a whole number of topic I
mean we are fundamentally political but
at the weekends have people go to our
site we have a lot of culture we you
know we write a fair amount about music
in fact we did a book serpent in the
garden essays and explorations or essays
and culture and sex which shows so to
speak the non directly political or
directly narrowly political
aspect of our life so Jeff and I and you
know we we have you know a lot of
wonderful people working with us Becky
Grant David wheeler and a Latina Rhea
working we feel very optimistic about
the way we're going this is the book
pavement you mentioned that was a 2004
Serpent's inner garden and for for
counterpunch just to double check on
this the website is free website is free
Wi-Fi org the we do a newsletter and you
subscribe to the newsletter which if you
order it up on our website as an email
you PDF you can get it for 35 bucks a
year 22 issue so that's not on the web
that is stuff that exclusive to
subscribe and we say you know it first
of all it's really good stuff we have we
have my you know wonderful material
whether it be an unlit we've got a very
good interesting piece coming up about I
can water the New York Times which has
been a very controversial area by Debbie
Nathan we had my brother Andrew and
Rumsfeld and torture we had Chris
Ketchum's piece on the Israel and 9/11
recently but to get that you have to you
have to subscribe and we say you like
our web site you can get that free but
if you want to donate in the form of
getting a subscription or you want to
donate anyway you can do that too our
guests this month on in depth Alexander
Coburn thank you very much for your time
thank you
tonight enough